la séance est ouverte le compte rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribuée il n'y a pas d'observation le
procès-verbal est adopté sous les
réserves d'usage mes chers collègues par
lettre en date de ce jour le
gouvernement demande de compléter
l'ordre du jour du mercredi 14 décembre
par l'examen des conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire sur le projet
de loi d'orientation et de programmation
du ministère de l'Intérieur
acte est donné de cette demande
l'ordre du jour appelle l'examen des
crédits de la mission cohésion des
territoires et article 41 ter du projet
de loi de finance pour 2023
et la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Baptiste BLANC rapporteur spécial
de la commission des finances pour 7
minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les crédits
de la mission cohésion des territoires
sont dans le projet de loi de finance
pour 2023 de 17,9 milliards d'euros
l'augmentation des crédits par rapport
au crédit totaux ouverts en 2022 de 411
millions d'euros mais cela correspond à
une diminution de 1,9% en neuroconstant
compte tenu de la prévision d'inflation
élevée en 2023 je vous présente les
quatre programmes qui portent les
crédits destinés aux politiques
d'hébergement d'aide au logement
d'urbanisme et de l'habitat ainsi qu'à
la politique de la ville on constate
essentiel sera que ce budget présenté
sans que le gouvernement est présenté
des objectifs clairs et tracer une ligne
je le constate sur le programme 177
hébergement parcours et le logement et
insertion des personnes vulnérables qui
portent la politique d'hébergement et
d'accès au logement des personnes sans
abri ou mal logé les crédits demandez
pour 2023 sur le programme 177 sont de
2,8 milliards d'euros ce qui correspond
en fait à une diminution en
neuroconstant par rapport à 202
si on prend en compte les crédits
ouverts en cours d'année une fois de
plus le programme 177 entame l’année
avec des crédits qui pourraient bien
apparaître comme sous-évalué en cours
d'année et ce d'autant que le
gouvernement n'a toujours pas défini
d'objectifs clairs pour la politique du
logement d'abord laquelle était une
priorité du quinquennat précédent cette
navigation a vu est encore plus évidente
pour la politique d'hébergement
d'urgence car le logement d'abord malgré
ses vertus n'a pas permis de réduire le
parc d'hébergement d'urgence toujours
situé à un niveau historiquement élevé
proche de 200 000 logements ce niveau
est un plateau dont il semble impossible
de redescendre puisque le gouvernement a
renoncé à l'objectif de réduire des
14000 places ce parc en 2023 les raisons
sont multiples et il est difficilement
envisageable de remettre à la à la rue
les personnes qui ont été hébergées
pendant la crise sanitaire la question
des migrants se pose également le
dispositif national d'accueil géré par
le ministère de l'Intérieur est saturé
et en gorge par voie de conséquence le
dispositif d'hébergement du programme
177 le programme 109 aide à l'accès au
logement comprend
[Musique]
attention l'Agence nationale de
l'habitat passe 170 millions d'euros à
plus de 400 millions auquel s'ajoutent
700 millions en provenant des ventes de
côte à carbone et 2,3 milliards sur le
programme 174 et la mission écologique
pour ma prise rénove toutefois il ne
suffit pas d'augmenter les crédits pour
colmater les brèches des maisons mâles
isolées il faut aussi agir sur la
structuration de l'offre car il manque
un véritable écosystème de la rénovation
globale des logements il faudrait plus
d'entreprises capables sur le marché de
la rénovation des logements privés il
faut certainement développer mieux les
dispositifs qui garantissent une
amélioration de la performance
énergétique et apporte un accompagnement
à des ménages qui n'ont pas la
compétence de maîtrise d'ouvrage pour
des rénovations globales or le
gouvernement se contente pour
l'essentiel d'abonder les crédits de
l'aide Mappy Venom de base certes plus
facile à mettre en oeuvre pour publier
des chiffres de réalisation
impressionnants mais dans l'efficacité
n'est pas suffisamment prouvée
s'agissant des logements sociaux
l'objectif de 250 000 logements sociaux
agréés en 2021 et deux annoncé par le
précédent gouvernement a été oublié et
on arrivera peut-être à 190 000 sur deux
ans aujourd'hui des objectifs du
gouvernement en matière de logement
social manque de clarté alors même que
le secteur fait face à la hausse
importante du taux de livret A sur
lequel ces intérêts d'emprunt sont
indexés Action Logement et soumis à une
pression
importante particulière d'une part
l'article 16 du projet de loi de finance
le sommet à une contribution de 300
millions pour financer les aides à la
pierre que le Sénat a supprimé d'autre
part et c'est sans doute encore plus
important sa filiale financière Action
Logement services a été classé par
l'INSEE en administration publique il
risque donc d'être interdite d'emprunt
sur plus de 12 mois c'est une décision
comptable qui risque d'affecter la
participation d'Action Logement aux
politiques publiques dont la mise en
oeuvre dépend de sa contribution a
commencé par le nouveau programme du
renouvellement urbain ce programme 135
en toute logique devrait également
contribuer au financement du Zéro
artificialisation nette donc le fameux
zan ce n'est malheureusement pas le cas
sauf indirectement via la dotation aux
établissements publics fonciers sur ce
point encore le gouvernement n'affiche
toujours aucune stratégie pour définir
un modèle économique d'usage le fond
friche qui a été très apprécié en 2021
et 22 c'est désormais fondu dans un fond
vert de la mission écologique
développement mobilité durable
c'est-à-dire que ni les modalités ni les
modalités d'attribution des crédits ne
sont connus à ce jour c'est un flou très
regrettable car il entraîne un risque de
démobilisation dans un domaine où la
vision de long terme est essentielle de
manière générale est essentielle que le
gouvernement s'empare réellement de la
question du financement et de la
fiscalité de l'objectif zan afin que les
communes yoi une opportunité et non une
contrainte imposée de manière
descendante j'en arrive pour finir à la
politique de la ville portée par le
programme 147 ses crédits sont de 598
millions d'euros en crédit de paiement
en augmentation de 40 millions par
rapport à la loi de finance initiale
pour 2022 mais quasiment constant en
euros constante ces crédits budgétaires
principalement consacré à une grande
diversité d'actions engagées dans le
cadre des contrats de ville mais les
résultats de cette politique sont
toujours aussi difficiles à percevoir
plus de 40% des adultes de 15 à 64 ans
résidant dans le quartier de la
politique de la ville reste à l'écart du
marché de l'emploi contre moins de 30 %
dans les autres quartiers des mêmes
unités
urbaines pour conclure il faut regretter
que le gouvernement cette année encore
repousse le moment où il apportera les
financements promis aux nouveaux
programmes de renouvellement urbain qui
dépend donc des contributions d'actions
logements et des bailleurs sociaux alors
qu'elle est dépenses de l'enrue
commencent à devenir importantes
dépassent dépassant les 500 millions dès
2022 cela n'est pas fait pour nous
rassurer compte tenu des incertitudes
pesant sur ces acteurs le point commun à
toutes ces analyses et que ce budget ne
présente aucune perspective clair sur le
la politique du logement et de
l'urbanisme dans les années à venir et
c'est la raison pour laquelle la
commission des finances a décidé de s'en
remettre à la sagesse du Sénat sur le
vote des crédits de la mission cohésion
des territoires elle a en revanche
donner un avis favorable à l'adoption de
l'article 41 TER qui permet d'éviter un
risque d'augmentation de la réduction de
loyer de solidarité pour les bailleurs
sociaux je vous remercie merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur Bernard
Delcourt rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances pour 7 minutes
également
bien madame madame madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre chers collègues il
me revient d'évoquer le volet à
dominante rural de la mission cohésion
des territoires avec les programmes 112
et 162 qui rassemble notamment des
crédits du FNA DT le programme 112 voit
cette année ses crédits augmentés
fortement de près de 35% notamment en
raison de crédit rapatrié de l'ancienne
mission plan de relance qui avait été
mise en place précédemment à cela
s'ajoute près de 700 millions d'euros de
dépenses fiscale portée par le programme
112 en faveur de territoires bénéficiant
de zonage spécifique cette version 2023
m'amène à évoquer plus particulièrement
trois sujets
premier sujet l'état poursuit sa
politique contractuelle avec les
territoires nous soutenons cette
stratégie les CPER nouvelle génération
et les CPER pour les massifs sont
désormais signés et opérationnels dans
la quasi-totalité des régions il
bénéficieront pour 2023 de 143 millions
d'euros en a eu et près de 56 millions
d'euros en CP et de près d'un milliards
d'euros sur la période des contrats 2022
les CRPE signaient à l'échelle locale et
piloté par la
nctuelle année de mise en œuvre je veux
saisir cette occasion pour rappeler que
les CRPE signer à l'échelle locale
doivent permettre aux élus de disposer
de visibilité sur les financements de
leurs investissements pour la durée des
contraintes c'est l'objet même d'une
contraculation plus réelle elle doit
s'appliquer dans tous les territoires de
France
le programme petite ville de demain
venue compléter fort utilement le
programme cœur de ville se poursuit en
2023 comme nous le souhaitions la notion
de pour centres sans critères de nombre
d'habitants a été retenu pour les
éligibilité des communes cet été
essentiel parce que le statut de Paul de
service pour un bassin de vie n'est en
aucun cas corrélé à son nombre
d'habitants
monsieur le ministre
programme cœur de ville programme petite
ville de domaine je pense qu'il faut
aller jusqu'au bout de cette logique
territoriale de cette stratégique que
nous approuvons de soutien au territoire
en mettant en place un programme village
d'avenir destiné à l'échelon communal
pourquoi pourquoi parce que cela
permettrait d'accompagner les
territoires jusqu'au plus proche des
habitants et d'ouvrir des perspectives
aux nombreux mères de petites communes
rurales qui se sentent exclues des
dispositifs existants le plan ruralité
que prépare la ministre en charge de la
ruralité pour donner une suite à
l'agenda rural me semble être la bonne
occasion pour mettre en place ce nouveau
dispositif et faire aboutir finalement
cette stratégie de soutien au territoire
deuxième sujet l'Agence nationale de
cohésion des territoires bénéficiera en
2023 au titre du programme 112 d'une
subvention pour charge de service public
de 63 millions d'euros
l'agence a aujourd'hui démontré son
intérêt même si elle a encore besoin de
renforcer sa visibilité à l'échelle
territoriale
elle a bénéficié en 2022 du hausse de 13
emplois sous plafond c'était nécessaire
au travers de la NCT le projet de budget
pour 2023 maintient les crédits à
l'accompagnement des collectivités
rurales en matière d'ingénierie à
travers des chefs de projets des
programmes PVD cœur de ville et
territoire d'industrie les volontaires
territoriaux en administration les
chargées de mission fabriquent de
territoire les conseillers numériques ou
encore les marchés abandonnent lancé par
l'État qui présente un réel intérêt pour
les territoires je rappelle que ces
crédits de soutien à l'ingénierie
interne et externe c'était important et
nous le demandions de 10 millions
d'euros à la création de la NCT il y a
deux ans ont été doublés en 202121 pour
être porté à 20 millions d'euros comme
nous l'avions demandé
l'agence pilote également le déploiement
de 2500 maisons francs services
auxquelles sont consacrées près de 37
millions d'euros en 2023 et de nouvelles
maisons devraient voir le jour dès
l'année prochaine après cette première
phase réussie pour les maisons un
service nous devons engager une nouvelle
étape avec pour objectif une offre de
service enrichie l'entrée de nouveaux
opérateurs des agents mieux formés et
aux métiers davantage reconnu l'accès à
tous les habitants faciliter et le
financement des maisons pérennisées et
revalorisés tel est le chantier amené en
2023 avec le ministre de la
transformation de la fonction publique
désormais en charge des maisons
françaises enfin j'en viens aux dépenses
fiscales portées par le programme sans
doute je l'ai dit près de 700 millions
d'euros elles sont associées à plusieurs
hommages cet au total ces zonage qui
arrivaient à échéance fin 2020 ont été
utilement progés jusqu'à fin 2023 comme
nous l'avions souhaité l'année qui vient
sera donc déterminante quant à l'avenir
de ces dispositifs
parmi eux je veux rappeler ça m'étonnera
personne l'attachement de tous les
ruraux au maintien des zones de
revitation rurale les fameuses ZRR et au
soutien qu'elles apportent à l'économie
au secteur médico-social au
collectivités leur maintien est une
nécessité pour le secteur rural je tiens
à insister sur ce sujet
concernant le programme 162
interventions territoriale de l'étain il
est doté pour 2023 de près de 86
millions d'euros en AE et 62 millions en
CP au delà de la reconduction des 8
actions déjà inscrites en 2022 le projet
de budget pour 2023 prévoit une nouvelle
action consacrée à la mise en oeuvre du
plan de lutte contre les Sargasses aux
Antilles dotées de 5,1 millions d'euros
chers collègues concernant les
programmes d'angélateur 112 et 162 je
suis à titre personnel favorable à la
option de leur crédit mais je rappelle
que le vote sur la mission est globale
et inclut donc le volet qu'a présenté
mon collègue Jean-Baptiste blanc et sur
l'ensemble de la mission comme il l'a
rappelé la commission des finances à
majoritairement et vit émis un avis de
Chazelle de sagesse pardon je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Madame Dominique Estrosi sa sonne
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires économiques pour 3 minutes
chers collègues
madame la Présidente Monsieur administre
mes chers collègues monsieur le
président de la commission des finances
monsieur le rapporteur spécial le budget
pour le logement qui nous est proposé
prolonge plus les orientations
antérieures qu'il ne fait de choix c'est
un budget de transition qui nous laisse
soit inquiet soit sur notre fin cette
entre deux est particulièrement sensible
sur trois dossiers clés le financement
du logement social la rénovation
énergétique et la construction neuve
concernant le financement du logement
social l'État a décidé de prolonger la
réduction du loyer de solidarité la RLS
d'une année supplémentaire avant toute
négociation d'impact de confiance avec
les bailleurs sociaux ou d'une
convention quinquennale avec Action
Logement ainsi l'article 16 du PLF avait
pour but de prélever une nouvelle fois
300 millions d'euros à Action Logement
tandis que l'article 41 TER maintient le
rendement budgétaire de la RLS à 1, 3
milliards d'euros pourtant il n'y avait
rien de naturel à cela le Fonds National
des aides à la pierre le Fnac n'a-t-il
pas vocation à être financé par l'État
plutôt que par les bailleurs sociaux la
RLS n'a-t-elle pas vocation à
disparaître ou pour le mois à décroître
face à la hausse des taux d'intérêt des
coûts de construction et aux enjeux de
rénovation HLM pour un ministre du
Logement n'est-ce pas mener une
politique à courte vue que de laisser le
ministère du Budget prendre de fait le
contrôle de 1% logement demain monsieur
le ministre qui financera la rénovation
urbaine ou option cœur de veille de
ville qui sont des programmes vitaux
pour les collectivités territoriales la
rénovation énergétique des logements est
le deuxième grand sujet la loi climat
est résilience a imposé un calendrier
resserré qui est susceptible d'avoir des
conséquences majeures sur le logement
car de très nombreuses résidences
principales sont classées E bouger un
geste attendu et depuis longtemps
proposé par le Sénat a été fait dans le
PLFR avec le doublement temporaire du
déficit foncier pour les propriétaires
de logement énergivore le PLF propose
une augmentation importante des crédits
de Lana mais Monsieur le Ministre
donnez-vous pour autant les moyens aux
Français de se lancer massivement dans
des rénovations globales qui leur
permettront de faire des économies
précieuses y compris lorsqu'ils habitent
en copropriété avez-vous entrepris une
levée systématique de tous les freins à
ses travaux car c'est toute une filière
qui doit se mettre en mouvement quant au
soutient à la construction neuve quelle
visibilité allez-vous donner le logement
nous le savons tous est un secteur de
temps long et d'investissement qui a
besoin d'un cadre stable et clair tout à
l'opposé de niche fiscales prolongée
d'une année sur l'autre ce cadre je
l'appelle de mes vœux pour
l'investissement locatif par exemple à
travers un statut du bailleur je
souhaite également que soit réhabiliter
l'acte de construire auprès des maires
et de nos concitoyens en sachant lier la
capacité financière à agir avec la
dynamique de construction de la
population sortant enfin de l'absurdité
de vouloir construire moins pour loger
plus et répondons vraiment aux besoins
des Français dans ce contexte la
commission des affaires économiques a
décidé de s'abstenir de la mission elle
n'a pas voulu afficher une opposition
face à des compromis qui pourraient être
constructifs mais elle n'a pas voulu
donner non plus l'impression
qu'elle ne partage pas
alors la parole est à Madame Viviane
Artigalas rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des affaires économiques pour
3 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur les
rapporteurs spéciaux mes chers collègues
le gouvernement propose pour 2023 des
crédits dédiés à la politique de la
ville augmentation de 7,1% soit 39,6
millions d'euros de plus c'est d'autant
plus positif que cette hausse s'inscrit
dans un effort quasi constant depuis
2017 c'est d'ailleurs cette constance
que je voudrais souligner de fait il n'y
aura guère de moyens vraiment nouveau
car l'essentiel servira à financer le
dispositif quartier d'été à hauteur de
30 millions d'euros qui est déjà en
place depuis trois ans et à une
enveloppe supplémentaire de 5 millions
d'euros pour des postes d'adultes relais
qui sont facés être déjà officiellement
ouverts par ailleurs le budget conforte
l'ensemble des actions préalablement
lancées notamment les 200 cités
éducatives pérennisées jusqu'en 2027 et
les bataillons de la prévention ceci
étant je ne veux pas minimiser notre
satisfaction les quartiers d'été sont
confortés et moyenne budgétique dès le
début d'année alors que depuis leur
création à l'issue du confinement en
2020 leur financement n'était assuré
qu'en cours d'année et parfois très
tardivement mettant les collectivités et
les associations dans une situation très
délicate ce dispositif était pourtant B
plébiscité par les maires en raison de
son impact positif en terme de
tranquillité publique et d'éducation je
serai plus critique concernant les
adultes relais en raison du décalage
entre les annonces officielles qui ont
porté le nombre des postes censés être
ouverts de 4000 à 6514 au cours du
quinquennat précédent et la réalité de
4600 personnes réellement à l'oeuvre sur
le terrain je voudrais monsieur le
ministre que vous vous attaquiez
vraiment aux causes du problème car on
sait que la présence au plus proche des
habitants est une des clés de la
réussite de la politique de la ville en
fait je voudrais insister une nouvelle
fois sur la situation de l'onpv pourtant
centrale pour l'évaluation vous le savez
notre commission a dénoncé le fait qu'il
soit devenu une coquille vide sans
personnel sans moyen et sans lien avec
la recherche ou Prex parce que ou en
êtes-vous de sa relance monsieur le
ministre enfin je veux évoquer la
contribution budgétaire de l'État onpn
rue le programme est entré en phase
active la rue va donc devoir avoir un
rythme de décaissement de l'ordre d'un
milliard d'euros par an au cours des 5
prochaines années or l'État ne tient pas
ses engagements il doit financer 1,2
milliards d'euros sur les 12 milliards
du programme d'ici 2031 de 2007 à 2022
malgré sa promesse d'apporter 200
millions d'euros seul 92 millions ont
été versés restent donc plus de 1,1
milliard d'euros à payer soit un rythme
de 110 millions par an environ or une
nouvelle fois en 2023 l'État ne bercera
que 15 millions c'est la crédibilité de
l'État qui est en jeu là aussi monsieur
le ministre nous attendons des
engagements en conclusion si je relève
positivement la constance du
gouvernement dans les politiques menées
et les moyens accordés à la politique de
de la ville les limites que j'ai
indiquées les inquiétudes pour l'avenir
alors que se préparent les futurs
contrats de ville on conduit la majorité
de la commission des affaires
économiques a proposé de s'abstenir sur
les crédits de la mission cohésion des
territoires merci chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur Alain Dufour
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires sociales pour 3 minutes
[Applaudissements]
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues le programme 177 des
structures d'hébergement qui permet de
lutter sans abri le nombre total des
places d'hébergement
financiers constituent le point nodal de
l'examen de ce programme et absorbe 98%
des crédits ne parles d'hébergement
accumulé un niveau inédit de plus de
23000 places en mars 2021 40000 places
de plus qu'en février 2020 il est le
printemps 2021 le gouvernement avait
fait part de son intention de maintenir
200000 places ouvertes jusqu'à 31 mars
2022 avant qu'une décrue progressive ne
soit amorcée au cours de cette année
pour atteindre le seuil de 186 000
places en 2023 le gouvernement a renoncé
néanmoins à son projet de réduction du
nombre de places et le programme 177 a
été abordé de 40 millions d'euros
supplémentaires ce soir va permettre de
répondre à l'urgence alors que la
demande déplace est encore très forte
mais nous le savons la lutte contre
sans-abrisme doit passer d'une réponse
construite dans l'urgence s'appuyant
majoritairement sur des places
d'hébergement un accès le plus rapide
possible logement avec donc
accompagnement social adapté aux besoins
c'est le sens du plan logement d'abord
qui arrive à son terme cette année ce
plan fait l'objet d'un consensus dans le
secteur ses objectifs sont partagés par
tous les secteurs associatifs depuis le
lancement du plan quinquennal en 2017
000 personnes hébergées ou sans abri ont
accédé au logement social à une ou une
solution logement adaptée avec des
résultats en émerveçons continuent c'est
sorti vers le logement dont toutefois
pas permis d'enregistrer une baisse de
vente d'hébergement d'urgence il faut
savoir quand même qu'en 10 ans les
crédits à louer au programme ont doublé
et ceux consacrés à l'hébergement
d'urgence ont été multipliés par 4 OH
monsieur le ministre nous attendons
l'annonce la prochaine séquence du plan
logement d'abord dans les délais les
problèmes néanmoins cette mission fait
ressentir un problème récurrent qui n'a
jamais été abordé c'est celui de
l'immigration alors pourquoi je dis ça
car sur les 200 000 places qui sont qui
ont été attribuées bien 15% sont des
nationaux reste des personnes sont en
situation irrégulière sans titre ou sans
papiers ou en passe des très sculptés
voilà situation que je voulais
aujourd'hui vous écrire est en préciser
que au regard des moyens financiers qui
sont proposés mais la commission des
affaires sociales sous cette remarque a
émis un avis favorable à l'option de ses
crédits je vous remercie merci chers
collègues la parole est un Louison de
Nicolaï rapporteur pour Avida commission
de l'aménagement du territoire et du
développement durable pour 3 minutes
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteurs mes chers collègues la
Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable à
émi un avis d'abstention à l'adoption
des crédits des programmes 112 et 162
contenu des faibles évolutions
constatées par rapport au budget pour
2022 dans le contexte actuel d'inflation
et de fragilisation croissante de
l'Agence nationale de la cohésion des
territoires premier point s'agissant de
la NCT je relève que l'agence atteint la
grande majorité des objectifs qui lui
avaient été assignés toutefois je crains
que les financements deviennent 2023 ne
lui permettent pas de remplir pleinement
sa mission de soutien les génériques sur
mesure des communes qui avaient justifié
sa création dans le cadre de la loi que
notre commission avait examiné en 2019
il ne faudrait pas que l'agence
ponctionne la ligne budgétaire de 20
millions d'euros prévu pour ce soutien à
une générique du fait des contraintes
qui s'imposent sur son sur son
fonctionnement dès lors il y a deux
solutions soit il faut attribuer des
moyens de fonctionnement à l'agence à
chaque fois qu'une mission nouvelle lui
est confiée soit il faut mobiliser ses
opérateurs partenaires pour qu'ils
apportent à l'agence des moyens de
fonctionnement la prochaine révision des
conventions plus réelles qu'il lit la
NCT à ses opérateurs partenaires la dame
séréma enrue Anna et Caisse des Dépôts
doit permettre de remettre sur la table
sujet de la coordination de
l'intervention de ces opérateurs
deuxième point la Commission estime
qu'il est nécessaire de définir une
nouvelle ambition pour les politiques à
destination des territoires ruraux la
réforme des zones de revitalisation
rurale les adrèrent est toujours au
point mort et des politiques
structurantes pour le territoire doivent
être amplifiés
la nouvelle mini chargée des
collectivités et de la ruralité annoncée
la préparation d'un acte 2 de l'agenda
rural et c'est une annonce et bienvenue
qui doit être concrétisée et qui
pourrait être prolongée par l'initiative
législatives et réglementaire notre
commission récemment formulée des
propositions sur le commerce en milieu
rural la logistique urbaine les déserts
médicaux et les ouvrages d'art nous
invitons le gouvernement à s'en saisir
je terminerai justement l'évoquant la
question des ouvrages d'art des
collectivités plus particulièrement des
ponts routiers notre Commission a publié
deux rapports sur le sujet en 2019 avec
Hervé Moret Patrick chaise et Michel
Dagbert puis en 2022 avec Bruno Belin
aussi nous examinerons tout à l'heure
des amendements visant à acter un
soutien financier de l'État aux
collectivité territoriale à la fois dans
le recensement le diagnostic de ces
ponts mais aussi et surtout pour les
accompagner dans la réparation des
ouvrages posant des problèmes de
sécurité le programme pont du céréma est
une première réponse intéressante mais
il faut l'amplifier trop de mères se
sont démunis sur ce sujet le chantier
colossal les besoins de financement
matière de travaux de réparation
représente 2 à 3 milliards d'euros
uniquement pour les ponts du bloc
communal enfin je défendrai un
amendement de Commission visant à
augmenter dans les propulsions modestes
le soutien de l'État à la reconquête de
la qualité de l'eau à Pays de la Loire
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
dans la suite de notre discussion je
vous rappelle que le temps de parole
attribue à chaque groupe pour chaque
unité de discussion comprend le temps
d'intervention générale et celui de
l'explication de vote par ailleurs le
gouvernement dispose au total de 15
minutes pour intervenir
alors la parole est à Monsieur Eric gold
pour le groupe du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen pour 5
minutes chers collègues
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues le budget de la mission
cohésion des territoires frôlera
pratiquement les 18 milliards d'euros de
crédit en 2023 ça peut sembler
conséquent chaque crédit compte puisque
cette mission se caractérise par la
recherche permanente de la solidarité
d'un côté garantira tous le droit de
vivre dans la dignité en permettant
l'accès à un logement décent et à défaut
à un toit et de l'autre assurer dans la
mesure du possible l'équité entre les
territoires de la République la crise de
structurelle du logement à laquelle
vient se superposer une crise
énergétique et une inflation qui
s'installe dans la durée nous préoccupe
le foncier continue de se raréfier alors
que nous devons poursuivre la lutte
contre l'artificialisation des sols les
objectifs ne sont pas tenus en matière
de production de logements sociaux le
parc de logement existant privé comme
public comprend environ 5 millions de
passwords thermiques quand la sécurité
d'approvisionnement énergétique et deux
ans et de moins en moins garanties
malgré les moyens consacrés annuellement
à la politique du logement soit environ
2% de notre produit intérieur brut les
loyers et les prix d'acquisition des
biens immobiliers demeurent très élevés
dans les villes les jeunes et les
ménages modestes peinent à accéder à la
propriété la part des primo-accédants
modestes n'est que de 21% de
soutiendront donc les amendements
déposés qui vise à rétablir l'APL
accession supprimer en 2018 ce type de
mesure devrait être privilégié par
rapport aux dispositif fiscaux pour
l'investissement locatif bien plus
coûteux pour les finances publiques
le développement de la construction ne
peut être une réponse partout alors que
nous disposons dans notre pays de bâti
inutilisé car fortement dégradé dont on
pourrait accompagner l'acquisition grâce
à des aides conséquentes et lisibles à
la rénovation plutôt de continuer à
favoriser à dispersion de la si la
montée en puissance de ma prime rénov
doit être salué les rénovations globales
ne parviennent pas à progresser encore
faut-il monsieur le ministre que l'on
n'entrave pas la réhabilitation des
logements et la redynamisation des
centres villes historiques composées
essentiellement de bâtiments énergivores
et dégradés qui se vide de leur habitant
notamment en secteur sauvegardé soit
plus de 40% 46% des communes aussi à
titre d'illustration je regrette que la
transformation de la vie conforme des
architectes de bâtiments de France en
avis simple pour l'installation de
panneaux photovoltaïques et finalement
pas été retenu au Sénat lors de l'examen
du projet de Loire relatif à
l'accélération de la production
d'énergie renouvelable
et surtout l'État doit prendre en main
la politique d'aménagement du territoire
et pour cela permettre aux élus locaux
de faire vivre leur territoire
la NCT n'est pas à notre sens doté de
moyens en ingénierie territoriale
suffisant le sur-mesure pour permettre
d'accompagner les élus dans la
réalisation de leurs projets
les programmes nationaux tel qu'action
cœur de ville ou petite ville de demain
sont bienvenus pour les collectivités
qui ont été retenues pour les autres en
particulier les communes et les
communautés de communes rurales elles ne
parviennent tout simplement pas à monter
les dossiers pour réaliser des projets
et obtenir des crédits
de surcroît 6 millions sur les 20
millions d'euros de l'enveloppe dédiée à
l'ingénierie territoriale a été puisée
pour financer des chefs de projet de
petite ville de demain or face au crédit
ouvert dans le cadre du plan de relance
puis maintenant du fond vert le manque
d'ingénierie territoriale et surtout
d'un guichet unique comme cela a été
annoncé par le président de la
République les pénalise et ne peut que
générer des frustrations
l'agence faitra ces trois ans
prochainement nous sommes persuadés que
la déconcentre déconcentration de ces
interventions doit être accélérée là où
les besoins sont avérés
le recours à des volontaires
territoriaux en administration ne peut
constituer une réponse satisfaisante les
crédits sont d'ailleurs sous consommés à
défaut de disposer d'un guichet unique
auprès de la NCT les préfectures étant
bien occupées par ailleurs le
recrutement de chef de projet métier qui
require une certaine expertise serait
plus pertinent pour venir soutenir les
communes et communités de communes
rurales dans cette fameuse logique
ascendante attendue par les élus nous
présenterons des amendements ce sens
enfin la transition écologique et
énergétique ainsi que la politique
d'aménagement du territoire ne pourront
être menées à bien sans la pleine
participation des collectivités sans une
cohésion harmonieuse entre les
territoires avec toutes ces remarques
mais on regarde les moyens qui seront
engagés en 2023 le groupe RDSE votera
les crédits de cette mission
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane sottarel pour le
groupe les républicains pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues messieurs les rapporteurs la
mission cohésion des territoires
comprend plusieurs programmes autour de
deux grands volets la politique des
territoires sur laquelle je m'arrêterai
plus longuement avec des programmes
spécifiques qui doivent encore renforcer
leur lisibilité pour une plus grande
efficacité une ambition accrue et celle
du logement et de l'urbanisme les
programmes 112 et 162 qui concerne la
première de ces politiques constituent
un des volets de l'action territoriale
qui figure dans le budget de l'État si
les moyens accordés à la NCT dont 20
millions d'euros sont consacrés à
l'appui des projets portés par les
territoires sont stables hors plan de
relance il est bien évident qu'il ne
répondent pas à l'intégralité des
besoins de nos territoires
c'est pourquoi il m'a paraît que d'une
part il conviendrait pour renforcer
l'ancrage local de la NCT expérimenter
un appui partenarial renforcé avec les
agences techniques départementales qui
en proximité sont les premières
interlocutrices des collectivités et
d'autre part de limiter notre corsaire
réglementaire et normatif pour faciliter
l'émergence des projets dans des délais
raisonnables il faut un effet sortir du
système d'autorisation préalable
généralisée pour toute décision que nous
connaissons avant de prendre une
décision ou de construire un équipement
on est de plus en plus obligé de
s'inscrire dans des schémas dans qui
imposent pardon qui s'impose ensuite aux
collectivités de faire actualiser une
somme de documents qui sont opposables
en droit et tout ça effectivement est
générateur de temps de délai qui ne sont
plus toujours compris cela oblige à
avoir une ingénierie technico juridique
administrative qui amplifie les
fractures territoriales en défavorisant
voire un excluent certaines
collectivités qui n'ont pas les moyens
nous devons absolument redonner
confiance dans cette procédure le réseau
France service quant à lui est proposé
en stabilité de crédit à hauteur de 36,3
millions d'euros nous arrivons à un
effet en vitesse de croisière du
déploiement de ces maisons qui
bénéficient d'un forfait
d'accompagnement financier à hauteur de
30.000 euros je vous saluer le travail
de notre rapporteur spécial Bernadette
très investi sur cette action qui a
conduit une mission de contrôle
éclairante confirmant la pertinence du
dispositif mais aussi certaines limites
et quelques pistes d'amélioration
notamment quand on renforcement de leurs
liens avec les communes du territoire à
ce titre je soutiens la démarche
suffisant à accroître le forfait alloué
pour tendre vers une participation à 55
ans l'objectif serait de parvenir à une
participation de l'État en effet et de
ses opérateurs de 50000 euros au titre
de ces missions de service public
national assuré par les communes et les
EPCI qu'il nous est pas possible
durablement de mobiliser au-delà de la
moitié du coût qui s'établit à 100 ou
110000 euros passer de 30 à 35000 euros
de forfait contributifs en 20 3 serait
déjà une première étape enfin la
question sensible des hommages et en
particulier des edrr doit être
rapidement traitée pour donner
lisibilité et garantie si on peut se
féliciter d'une prorogation du système
actuel jusque au 31 décembre 2023 comme
ça a été rappelé il est clair qu'il
faudra très vite harmoniser le zonage
adapter les mesures sur la base de
l'évaluation réalisée et sans doute
introduire des mesures nouvelles de
valorisation renforcées des aménitaires
rurales qui seraient plus positives
encore
concernant le volet logement et
urbanisme qui concerne 17,9 milliards
d'euros en plus de la dépense fiscale de
15,9 milliards et des ressources
affectées je me contenterai d'une seule
observation qui constitue aujourd'hui
l'inquiétude majeure sur tous nos
territoires ruraux il s'agit bien sûr de
la mise en place du zan qui doit être
assouplie territorialisée et
différencier
la mission de contrôle
transversale et transpartisane sous
l'égide de notre collègue Jean-Baptiste
blanc qui rendra je crois c'est ces
conclusions et des propositions sous une
dizaine de jours devrait être éclairante
de ce point de vue là et j'espère
qu'elle sera entendue il s'agit à la
fois de rendre Homer la capacité à
maîtriser l'aménagement de leur
territoire au territoire ruraux à ne pas
être victime de la double peine à savoir
avoir peu consommé d'espace dans le
passé et donc avoir encore moins des
besoins d'équipements d'une part et
d'autre part devoir être les plus gros
contributeurs à la non artificialisation
des sols ils doivent garder une capacité
à agir dans nos territoires mes chers
collègues nous manquerons
malheureusement probablement
d'agriculteurs avant de manquer de
terrain agricoles il faut donc que
l'espace qui est notre richesse soit
maîtrisée par les acteurs locaux
j'aurais interviendrai dans le débat sur
cette question qui me semble essentielle
et sur laquelle nous devons donner des
gages à nos territoires je vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Jacques fermier pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire pour 5
minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président de
commission messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues cette mission budgétaire
rassemble des dispositifs relevant de
trois commissions permanentes de notre
assemblée elle traite en partie du
logement de l'hébergement d'urgence de
la politique de la ville des outils de
contractualisation entre l'État des
collectivités de l'action de la NCT en
appui au projet territoriaux et d'une
série d'interventions territoriales
ciblée entre autres algues vertes en
Bretagne chloredecones en Martinique
Guadeloupe bref une mission assez
disparate mais dont les composants
différents nécessitent en commun un
renforcement des dispositifs de soutien
pour contrer les basculements dans la
précarité et lever les obstacles à
gravés par les crises aux dynamiques de
nos territoires en transition disons
d'emblée que pour ce qui est de se
renforcement le compte n'y est pas tout
à fait puisqu'à périmètre constant en
intégrant l'inflation les crédits de
cette mission devraient diminuer en
volume de près de 2%. dernièrement dans
le temps imparti voici les principales
appréciations préoccupations et
propositions de mon groupe d'abord nous
ne discernons pas vraiment dans les
trois programmes dédiés au logement une
vision politique et des orientations
nouvelles conséquentes répondant à
l'ampleur du mal logement régulant de
façon volontariste les prix dans du
loyer que du foncier procurant au
bailleur sociaux les marges de manœuvre
à la hauteur des besoins criants
permettant aux primo-occident aux
primo-accédants aux étudiants et aux
jeunes couples d'accéder au logement
dans les coeurs de nos métropoles et les
zones touristiques colonisées par les
Airbnb les résidences secondaires les
locations saisonnières et de trop
nombreux logements vacants face à
l'absence de réelles volonté d'y
répondre par des crédits à la hauteur
mon groupe votera bien sûr les
amendements visant à améliorer les APL
aider l'accession à la propriété des
ménages modestes réduire les logements
inadaptés aux personnes dépendantes
hébergées les femmes victimes de
violence pour ce qui est de
l'hébergement d'urgence la forte tension
a obligé le gouvernement a annulé la
réduction prévue de 14000 places face à
l'ampleur du nombre de personnes de
famille d'enfants à la rue survivant
dans des conditions indignes dans nos
grandes villes notamment à Strasbourg
l'État ne peut laisser sans appuyer réel
nos collectivités en première ligne face
à ces drames humains sur lesquels les
engagements au plus haut niveau n'ont
pas été tenus les collectivités
impactées souhaitent travailler sur ces
hébergements d'urgence avec un état
réceptif à leur proposition avec un état
facilitateur on y arrivera mieux sur le
front du logement encore la vraie
nouveauté c'est le renforcement des
moyens de Lana pour la rénovation
thermique la dernière note de France
stratégie convaincra sans doute ceux qui
n'avaient pas pris toute la mesure du
gouffre énergétique qui est notre parc
résidentiel ma prime rénove prend certes
son ampleur mais son bilan énergétique
avéré et bien plus réduit il représente
pour l'instant
0,45% d'éc sur la consommation totale du
parc résidentiel nous sommes encore très
loin de rénovation globale mise en
oeuvre de manière massifiée le groupe
écologiste proposera à notre Sénat
d'enquêter de proposer de façon
approfondie pour que ces politiques
publiques trouvent les voies de
l'efficacité sur le front des quartiers
de la politique de la ville la
persistance d'une pauvreté d'un chômage
nettement plus important oblige à
amplifier nos actions publiques le
nouveau programme national de
renouvellement urbain est entré en phase
active si les bailleurs sociaux et
Action Logement sont au rendez-vous
l'État n'a pas pour sa part tenu ses
engagements soit un rythme de 110
millions par an avec 15 millions pour
2023 ça vient d'être appelé on en est
loin avec un observatoire de la
politique de la ville en panne et
indigent on est loin encore d'avoir
l'outil d'évaluation qu'il faudrait au
moment où les perspectives financières
des collectivités s'assombrissent
lourdement ou leur capacité à mener
leurs indispensables investissements
d'avenir et fragiliser les programmes et
dispositifs d'accompagnement à leur
profits apparaissent d'autant plus
essentiel dans ce contexte tendu
l'Agence nationale de la cohésion des
territoires ne peut se borner à une
stabilité de ses moyens au regard de ces
missions notamment pour le déploiement
de nombreux programmes nationaux
l'accompagnement d'ingénierie des élus
pour les aider à concrétiser leur propre
projet le budget de la NTT est
manifestement insuffisant enfin mon
groupe est de ceux nombreux ici qui
pensent que l'État doit renforcer sa
part de prise en charge des maisons
France services celles-ci sont des
palliatifs utiles au recul des services
publics dans les territoires de la
République je proposerai d'ailleurs un
amendement d'autant les maisons France
services d'une compétence et de moyens
pour l'accompagnement et le conseil en
mobilité avec l'avènement des AFE et la
décarbonation accélérée des déplacements
voilà un service d'intérêt public qui
s'impose puisqu'il me faut conclure vous
aurez compris que le vote de mon groupe
sur les crédits de cette mission sera
complètement conditionnée au sort qui
sera fait aux nombreux amendements
nécessaires pour que soit contrées les
basculements dans la précarité et lever
les obstacles aux dynamiques de nos
territoires en transition
merci chers collègues oui c'est très
bien
la parole est à Madame Nadège avait pour
le groupe rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants pour 6
minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
doté de 60 milliards d'euros dans ce
projet de loi de finances pour 2023 les
ministères de la transition écologique
de la cohésion des territoires de la
transition énergétique voient leur
budget atteindre un niveau inédit des
moyens d'ampleur face à des défis nous
le savons colossaux la mission qui nous
occupe ce matin en temps soutenir la
cohésion des territoires en accompagnant
les collectivités territoriales dont les
ressources sont confortées et en
maintenant notre mobilisation en faveur
des territoires et des personnes les
plus fragiles les crédits qui sont
dédiés sont en hausse de 3,7% en
autorisation d'engagement par rapport à
2022 et de 3,9% en crédit de paiement je
veux revenir tout d'abord sur ce
affectés à l'hébergement et au logement
à savoir les programmes 109 135 et 177
dotés à eux seuls de près de 17
milliards d'euros il est à noter la
progression
possible des moyens alloués à l'Agence
nationale de l'habitat qui ont plus que
doublé afin de couvrir la création de 25
postes supplémentaires d'accompagner le
déploiement du réseau France trenov et
de préparer l'adaptation des logements
au vieillissement de la population avec
le déploiement de ma prime adapt de même
le budget consacré aux aides
personnalisées au logement augmentent
quant à lui de près de 300 millions
d'euros pour accompagner les décisions
que nous avons prises cet été avec la
revalorisation des aPL de l'ordre de
3,5% pour lutter contre l'inflation il
se situe à 13,3 milliards d'euros le
programme 177 qui s'élève à 2,8
milliards d'euros et destiné à l'accès
au logement pour les personnes
sans-abris ou mal logés les capacités
d'accueil du parc que d'hébergement
généralisée financé par l'État seront
renforcés pour atteindre 197000 places
d'hébergement l'année prochaine grâce à
une enveloppe supplémentaire de 40
millions d'euros il est aussi prévu le
financement de la revalorisation des
métiers du secteur accueil hébergement
insertion
la matière de politique de la ville à
travers le programme 147 l'engagement
financier du gouvernement se poursuit là
encore avec une hausse de 7% des crédits
celle-ci est supérieure à l'inflation
antisepée et est en augmentation
constante depuis 5 ans les objectifs
poursuivent le financement du dispositif
quartier d'été qui rentre contre un
grand succès dans nos campagnes
accompagner la montée en puissance de
l'établissement pour l'insertion dans
l'emploi financer des postes d'adultes
relais supplémentaires qui permettront à
des personnes sans emploi ou bénéficiant
d'un contrat d'accompagnement dans
l'emploi d'assurer des missions de
médiation sociale et culturelles de
proximité assurer la continuité de
plusieurs politiques initiées il y a
quelques années et je pense tout
particulièrement aux deux sens cités
éducatives qui sont pérennisées jusqu'en
2027 cela donnera de la visibilité à ces
nouveaux cadres locaux de coordination
visant à mieux accompagner les jeunes
dans leur parcours éducatif de leur
naissance jusqu'à leur insertion
professionnelle le programme 112 a quant
à lui fait l'objet pour la coordination
de la politique d'aménagement des
territoires pour assurer l'égal accède
et citoyens à un socle de service
fondamentaux je ferai ici référence à 5
actions principales l'accompagnement des
maisons France services il en existe
désormais une trentaine labilisée dans
le Finistère et plus d'une demi plus de
2000 sur le territoire national la
déclinaison de la gendaryle à travers
notamment petite ville de demain le
programme territoire d'industrie les
contrats de plomb et ta région ou encore
le plan action corps de ville dont le
second volet vient d'être annoncé le
dispositif gouvernemental restera le
même avec un axe environnemental fort et
une enveloppe de 5 milliards d'euros sur
quatre ans en lieu de 6 de son côté la
NCT voit sa subvention pour charge de
service public stabilisés à travers le
programme 162 il s'agit de mettre à
disposition des acteurs locaux de l'État
une enveloppe budgétaire unique fongie
fongivilisée en provenance des
programmes multiples plusieurs sont là
aussi consacrés à très bon problématique
environnemental territorial je citerai
la continuité du financement de l'action
haut et agriculture en Bretagne qui vise
à réduire le développement des algues
vertes ou encore la création d'une
nouvelle action afin de lutter contre la
prolifération des algues Sargasses aux
Antilles 14 communes sont concernées en
Guadeloupe et 9 en Martinique
globalement il s'agit donc de constater
une continuité bienvenu des politiques
publiques en la matière celles mises en
place depuis 2017 avec une nouvelle fois
une dimension environnementale
prépondérante notre groupe se prononcera
en faveur de ses crédits je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Denis Boine pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances monsieur des rapporteurs
dans son discours de politique générale
à madame la Première ministre rappelait
que la plus pour la plupart des Français
le logement et la première dépense
malheureusement malgré cette réalité les
politiques du logement n'ont pas fait
partie des grandes priorités de la
précédente législature
1,4 milliards d'euros qui sont prélevés
chaque année sur les autres pH à travers
la RLS en sont la plus brillante
illustration dès 2018 les bailleurs
sociaux alertés sur les conséquences
d'une telle disposition une Claude de
revoyure avait été décidé j'entends ceux
qui disent que malgré les secousses la
circulation financière des organes HLM
est aujourd'hui stabilisés
j'entends parfois le même discours au
sujet des finances des collectivités
locales alors oui les bailleurs sociaux
comme les collectivités sont des
gestionnaires responsables mais à quel
prix la construction de logements
sociaux sur le ministre a diminué de 36%
en quelques armées ce constat doit nous
inciter à sortir cette approche
comptable la simple stabilisation
financière des organismes ne peut pas
être un objectif suffisant à l'heure ou
plus de 2 millions de Français sont dans
l'attente d'un logement social
d'urgence de l'inflation ne doit pas
nous empêcher d'agir durablement pour le
pouvoir d'achat des Français à travers
des politiques structurantes
le logement pourrait être la première de
ces politiques et le logement social le
premier de vos leviers cette personne
sur le rappeler son éligibles en
logements social y habiter un permis en
moyenne une économie de 227 euros par
mois à l'heure où le marché de
l'immobilier accentue les inégalités
mesurant la portée de ces chiffres
nous avons entendu l'annonce dans la
première ministre d'impact de confiance
avec les acteurs du logement social
dans le cadre de remise en place de la
RS serait un bon premier pas pour
dessiner les contours de cette confiance
le fait de reconnaître le logement
social comme une politique de première
nécessité de vis-à-vis de la nation en
soutenant l'ensemble des investissements
des organisations à une TVA réduite à un
taux de 5,5 serait également un très bon
signal aussi je regrette que les
amendements que nous avons déposés en ce
sens ne sont pas été retenus par le PC
PLF
par ailleurs la flambée du prix de
l'énergie
exige des réponses urgentes et ciblées
pour une application sans faille du
bouclier tarifaire elle le met également
en lumière la nécessité d'accélérer la
rénovation énergétique de logements en
priorisant des ménages précaires par la
mise en place d'un prêt à taux zéro il
faut favoriser les travaux plus
ambitieux pour camper en perçoivent les
signes concrets d'une sans transition
énergétique trop inefficace trop
inégalitaire nous y reviendrons bien sûr
dans le débat
s'agissant du nouveau du nouveau plan
logement d'abord
quels seront les orientations et surtout
quelles seront les moyens pour affronter
l'accompagnement social encore trop
insuffisant pour les plus précaires
à contrario certaines ont amendements
ont été retenus certaines mesures vont
dans le bon sens que sur le ministre je
pense à ma prive adapte qui favorisera
la datation des logements vieillissement
de la population ici là il s'agit là
d'un véritable défi pour notre société
et nous devons nous nommer les moyens de
le relever nous sommes donc heureux de
cet amendement que nous avons proposé
pour en corriger la cohabitation
intergénérationnelle et soit retenu nous
sommes également satisfaits de la
tension de l'adoption de notre demande
concernant le prolongement du prêt à
taux zéro jusqu'en 2026 c'est un sujet
important qu'à l'obtention de crédit
immobilier de plus en plus contrainte
pour les ménages modestes
dans le même optique nous voterons
l'amendement qui est porté pendant le
reporter concernant l'APL d'accession
c'est une aide qui a un véritable effet
déclencheur pour de nombreux ménages
malgré quelques avancées positives ce
budget logement ne démarre se démarque
pas des politiques menées lors du
précédent quinquennat si cela peut
s'expliquer quand on dit du calendrier
nous espérons vivement que le prochain
sera celui de la rupture
monsieur le ministre
de nombreux signaux d'alerte sont
aujourd'hui rouges en ce qui concerne
logement des Français le parcours
résidentiel tel qu'ils connaissait il y
a 30 ans n'existe plus la part des
ménages propriétaires de la résidence
principale ne progresse plus la tension
entre l'offre la demande de cesse de se
renforcer le nombre de résidences
secondaires et de logements occasionnels
augmentent plus vite que l'ensemble du
parc enfin la disponibilité du foncier
son prix qui ont de plus en plus
contraintes y compris dans les
territoires ruraux monsieur le ministre
face à ce constat au nom des sénateurs
socialistes d'autres collègues le
président Patrick nous a rappelé à faire
du logement la Grande Cause Nationale de
ce quinquennat
nous ne pouvons pas nous satisfaire des
dispositions qui sont prises dans un
projet de loi de finance 2023 mais nous
espérons toujours que cet appel soit
entendu et que le logement sera demain
la Grande Cause Nationale du prochain
projet de loi des finances
merci chers
[Musique]
publicain citoyen et écologiste pour 5
minutes
monsieur le ministre madame la
Présidente Mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues la crise du
logement non seulement perdure mais
s'amplifie le logement coûte trop cher
plomb de plus en plus le pouvoir d'achat
de nos concitoyens la construction de
logements est particulièrement de
logements sociaux ou abordables
s'effondre les logements indignes ne se
résorbent pas et même avec le
vieillissement du parc ils sont de plus
en plus nombreux et de plus en plus
dangereux
la résorption des passoires thermiques
n'a pas trouvé un rythme de croisière
permettant d'atteindre des objectifs de
la loi climat énergie
d'une certaine façon monsieur le
ministre vous le reconnaissez il y a
quelques jours on indiquant on doit tous
se mobiliser pour que le logement ne
devienne pas la bombe sociale de demain
ce budget répondit à cet injonction la
réponse était là non
aucun réel progrès n'y était ni est
inscrit pour enrayer cette crise et pire
certains reculent ils sont consacrés
d'abord ce budget ne propose aucune
décision qui répare les graves erreurs
du précédent quinquennat
qu'il s'agisse de la PL du prélèvement
sur les bailleurs HLM avec la RLS le
niveau de la TVA pour le logement social
rien pour réguler les dérives de prix en
particulier ceux du Foussier qu'il
serait grand temps d'encadrer pour
stopper cette spirale haussière qui
renchérit indument la production de
logements accentue la ségrégation
sociale et spatiale
il serait pourtant urgent de s'attaquer
à la rente foncière
ce budget ne répond pas non plus à
l'urgence sociale et ne prend pas en
compte l'impact redoutable de
l'inflation et de la hausse des prix de
l'énergie
votre gouvernement n'a pas retenu la
proposition de gel des loyers que défend
notre groupe et a fixer à 3,5 la hausse
de l'IRL soit un niveau supérieur à la
hausse moyenne des salaires cette année
de fait cette décision va pénaliser le
pouvoir d'achat d'un grand nombre de
foyers
des aPL ne devraient pas augmenter ne
devrait augmenter que de 3,5%. ce qui ne
compense pas la hausse effective de la
quittance qui comprend non seulement les
loyers mais aussi les charges locatives
en particulier le chauffage
or ces derniers augmentent très
fortement et le bouclier énergétique ne
couvre pas l'entièreté de ses os de plus
de nombreux locataires HLM n'en
bénéficient toujours pas
nous regrettons que le forfait charge
des aPL qui n'avaient pas été
revalorisés depuis 12 ans ne soit pas
fortement augmenté cette année ou tout
pourtant le justifie les deux euros de
juillet ne suffisent évidemment pas vous
auriez pu à cet effet
mobiliser les 1,5 millions d'euros
économisés par l'État sur le dos des
populations modestes avec la mise en
place de la contemporalité des aPL sans
en revaloriser le niveau
refus de taxeries sur profit mes
ponction sur les APL et les bailleurs
sociaux oui monsieur le ministre celle
terreau d'une bombe sociale
la hausse du taux du livret A s'ajoute
au maintien de la RLS dont nous
demandons labrogation
obéran de façon inquiétante les
capacités des organismes HLM de
construire rénover entre dire leur parc
ce budget consacre le total des
engagement de l'État dans l'aide à la
pierre pour le logement social qui
pourtant on a fortement besoin
il en a besoin
excusez-moi il en a besoin pour produire
plus pour des loyers moins chers et
mieux adapté aux ressources des familles
le snap n'est plus abondé par l'État
depuis plusieurs années mais seulement
après les bailleurs sociaux et Action
Logement si cette année il est maintenu
au même niveau que précédemment ce qui
est déjà très insuffisant et ne suit pas
l'importante aux égouts des travaux
c'est au prix d'un prélèvement de 300
millions sur Action Logement
le Sénat a bien voté un amendement
contestant ce prélèvement mais en même
temps très clairement signifier qu'il
devait être compensés par l'État et
qu'il ne saurait y avoir du coup une
baisse de la dotation du snap le
maintien de la dotation du snap doit
être garantie c'est pour ne groupe une
priorité absolue et je le crois pour
notre Sénat car le Fnac est le seul
outil qui a sur vraiment l'égalité
d'accès et de subventions pour tous les
organismes HLM quel que soit leur statut
l'accession sociale à la propriété
semble avoir disparu des radars du
gouvernement c'est pourtant tout à la
fois une inspiration de nos concitoyens
comme un atout pour le parcours
résidentiel et dans bien des cas pour la
mixité sociale
l'absence d'engagement sur le PTZ
au-delà de 2023 contre le lancement de
nouveaux projets ce n'est pas acceptable
et d'ailleurs j'espère que vous
accepterez l'amendement du Sénat je
termine enfin pour dire que la hausse
des taux la restriction de l'accès au
crédit qui pénalise les catégories
populaires et moyennes nécessitent une
prime d'accession sociale pour y
remédier pour leur rien n'est prévu
alors dans ces conditions mes chers
collègues monsieur madame la Présidente
et Monsieur le Ministre le groupe CRCE
ne votera pas ce budget merci la parole
est à madame la Présidente Valérie
l'État pour le groupe Union centriste
pour 8 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre
[Musique]
messieurs madame les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues
au-delà du seul exercice comptable et
budgétaire la mission dont nous
discutons aujourd'hui mais c'est aussi
valable plus largement pour le PLF doit
nous amener à réfléchir au modèle de
société que nous souhaitons soutenir
pour les générations futures et pour
notre pays cette discussion intervient
dans un contexte que nous savons
perturbé au lendemain d'une crise
sanitaire nous concitoyens doivent
désormais faire face à des difficultés
liées à l'inflation à la crise
énergétique et aux nombreuses
incertitudes qui en découlent
à ces crises vient s'ajouter celle du
logement nous le savons nous devons
relever de nombreux défis rendres plus
sobre nos logements pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone continuent de
construire pour soulager les zones
tendues et faire face à la demande en
tout territoire et favoriser le parcours
résidentiel source d'épanouissement
familiales et personnel de nos
concitoyens c'est pourquoi nous
entendons rappeler aujourd'hui au sein
de cette émission que le logement
monsieur le ministre est bien de
première nécessité et non pas une
variable d'ajustement des politiques
publiques de l'État à ce titre nous
soutenons les mesures prises dans le
secteur de l'hébergement des personnes
vulnérables nous saluons la
revalorisation des métiers du secteur
accueil hébergement insertion qui
représentera 148 millions d'euros de
plus en 2023 ainsi que les nouveaux
développements en matière de logement
d'abord destinés au plus fragile à
hauteur de plus de 44 millions d'euros
notre pays doit rester fidèle au
principe d'accueil inconditionnel le
gouvernement a d'ailleurs accepté
d'amonder le budget initial de 40
millions donc pour maintenir les 95 000
places d'hébergements Renault sang ont
baissé ainsi le nombre ce qui veut quand
même dire monsieur le ministre que tout
en assurant effectivement ce principe
inconditionnel il faut que l'État mette
les moyens et créer les conditions pour
qu'ils ne soient pas dévoyés et qu'ils
soient maîtrisés
ce volume de place qui a augmenté
pendant la crise covid doit être
maintenue il constitue donc désormais un
plateau qu'on ne peut restreindre nous
resterons vigilants sur ce point sur le
plan budgétaire des efforts importants
sont également réalisés pour la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments et
du logement en effet la nave voit son
budget s'accroître de 900 millions
d'euros via le programme 174 et 219
millions grâce à l'affectation de
recettes de côte à carbone dans un
contexte où la France se fait rappeler à
l'ordre pour son retard en matière de
rénovation énergétique des logements
Lana doit en se forcer son intervention
rappelons qu'entre 2019 et 2021 tout est
confondu le décaissement du réseau les
décaissements du réseau ont été
multipliés par 3 le nombre de logements
aidé par 5 concernant ma prime rénove le
compte n'y est pas totalement malgré les
moyens conséquents elle a été attribuée
à 644 000 logements 2021 pour un montant
moyen de 3200 euros ma prime rénove
sérénité a permis même cette année la
rénovation de plus de 41 000 logements
dont plus de 23 ont 23000 ont bénéficié
d'une bonification pour sortie de
password thermique ma prime rénov copro
fait son chemin avec en 2021 12000
logements concernés nous saluons la
revalor les enveloppes déléguées à Lana
attendez j'ai fait j'ai sauté une page
concernant pour terminer l'enveloppe
Anna il y a un dernier point sur lequel
vous voulez peut-être porter votre
attention c'est que si effectivement
côté ma prime rénove on voit bien que
les efforts sont conséquents il manque
malgré tout dans ce dispositif une
réflexion véritable pour avoir les mêmes
ambitions de massification qu'il s'agit
du crédit d'impôt qui n'est plus là pour
les classes moyennes qui sont
aujourd'hui en difficulté par rapport à
un effort significatif d'accompagnement
de massification de la rénovation des
logements et vous dire aussi que sur les
enveloppes déléguées au préfet de région
il y a des régions où ces enveloppes
sont insuffisantes puisque dans la
mienne il manque 40 millions et nous
sommes obligés de rattraper de rattraper
année après année des retards
d'instruction de dossiers
il faut intensifier aussi donc c'est
politique de sobriété énergétique
les objectifs atteints sont de sont
aussi confrontés à de nombreuses
injonctions contradictoires qui sont
posées aux acteurs du logement de
l'interdiction progressive de louer des
passoires thermiques votées dans la loi
climat au zéro artificialisation nette
et j'associe à ces réflexions bien sûr
mon collègue Jean-Baptiste blanc en tant
que rapporteur et ça déclinaison dans
nos territoires la transition
énergétique dans notre pays devient trop
souvent synonyme d'une vision décliniste
du logement à la lecture de ce budget il
nous paraît il nous faudrait construire
moins pour loger plus comme le rappel
notre rapporteur Dominique Estrosi
l'équation est manifestement insolvable
le secteur de la construction de
logements neuves étant en grande
souffrance or on ne peut prétendre
pouvoir vouloir protéger les générations
futures si on ne l'air on ne leur laisse
pas de place pour se construire leur
foyer il ne s'agit pas là de faire le
procès de la transition écologique bien
au contraire elle est indispensable elle
dérive Coran au ménages dans la maîtrise
de leur charge et continuerait bien sûr
à défendre la nécessité d'agir en ce
sujet mais il y a aussi l'objectif
poursuivi et sa mise en oeuvre et il y a
évidemment la nécessité de marcher sur
deux jambes la jambe de la rénovation la
jambe de la construction la mission de
contrôle que j'ai l'honneur de présider
sur le sujet de la zéro
artificialisation nette avec notre
rapporteur Jean-Baptiste blanc sera
force de proposition aussi sur les
ambitions nécessaires à corriger pour
faire en sorte que le zan et l'acte de
construire reste évidemment et bien
convergent
nous le voyons ce conflit entre des
objectifs de politique publique majeure
est aujourd'hui manifeste et les choix
politiques opérés là où ils auraient dû
et pu s'inscrire dans une logique de
développement durable semble avoir
omis l'aspect économique et social au
profit du seul aspect environnemental là
où ils doivent raisonner ensemble
au travers de l'examen on constate cette
année une augmentation du financement
des aPL à hauteur de 292 millions
d'euros il s'agit ici de la traduction
des décisions votées cet été dans le
projet de loi pouvoir d'achat qui
prévoit d'accroître de 3,5% les
paramètres de calcul des aPL en raison
de l'inflation nous pourrions nous en
féliciter s'il ne s'agit c'est là que
d'une mesure de réaction qui nous
rappelle avant tout le contexte dans
lequel il s'inscrit une crise du
logement cette dernière n'épargne pas le
nombre de le monde du logement social
aux difficultés déjà malheureusement
bien connues les bailleurs sociaux
fragilisés depuis 2018 par la RLS voit
leurs difficultés se renforcer
normalement en ce qui concerne le manque
d'autofinancement ils ne dispose plus
des mêmes moyens pour financer les
nouveaux programmes de construction la
rénovation thermique des logements et
donc des risques leurs locataires
multiplie les alertes sur la hausse des
coûts de production des taux d'intérêts
et l'impératif toujours plus prégnant de
rénovation et de construction
nous devons être davantage attentif face
à ces signaux et même offensis monsieur
le ministre l'État doit être offensif
les doigts l'État doit reprendre toute
sa place et financer les politiques du
logement plutôt que d'aller chercher les
moyens chez les acteurs qui sont des
partenaires mais qui ne doivent pas être
au défi en
je alors dans un contexte particulier ou
comme je viens de le dire le secteur du
logement manque de visibilité il
convient de souligner en plus la
pression exercée par le gouvernement sur
Action Logement mes collègues l'ont tous
déjà rappelé mais ce point il est
particulièrement important c'est pas
vous que je vais la prendre monsieur le
ministre vous le savez pertinemment
d'abord il y a 2,2 millions de foyers
qui sont en attente de logements sociaux
aujourd'hui donc quand on nous explique
qu'il ne faut plus construire qu'on est
en train de décliner sur les demandes on
peut décliner un moment avant d'avoir
2,2 millions de solutions pour les 2,2
millions de familles qui attendent
toujours d'avoir un logement alors on
peut rénover on peut dire qu'il y a des
logements vacants mais où sont-ils
vacants à l'endroit où on en a besoin je
ne suis pas sûr et les déco hobbitations
il y a des territoires dans lesquels ce
ne sera pas possible alors mes chers
collègues Action Logement a besoin comme
nous l'avons fait dans le cadre de
l'amendement qui est passé à l'article
16 actions logements a besoin bien
évidemment d'être soutenu pour être au
rendez-vous de de décarbonation et enfin
monsieur le ministre permettez-moi de
vous dire que il faut sans attendre le
PLF de l'année prochaine envisager un
vrai plan décarbonation une vraie un
vrai engagement de l'État comme acteur
et financeur d'une politique de logement
à la hauteur des besoins de ce pays et
des 30 % que représente le monde du
logement dans cette politique de
décarbonation merci c'était 8 minutes
c'était pas neuf
la parole est à Monsieur François
bonhomme pour le groupe les républicains
pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre ces
programmes
touche à une question essentielle des
moyens à la mise en oeuvre de la
politique d'aménagement et de cohésion
du territoire il faut dire préalablement
que l'éclatement des crédits qui
concourent à cet objectif ne facilite
pas une analyse globale des moyens de
cette politique pas plus d'ailleurs que
une analyse d'une éventuelle stratégie
il faut dire aussi que le fléchage des
crédits je pense à une partie de ceux du
plan de relance du ministère de
l'Économie complique l'analyse par
manque de lisibilité
concernant le programme 112 impulsion et
coordination de la politique
d'aménagement du territoire on pourrait
saluer une hausse mais celle-ci n'est
que de façades si l'on considère les
crédits pour 2022 et ce prévu dans la
mission du plan de relance qui ont été
transférés en gestion à ce programme 112
c'est bien une baisse qu'on constate
tant en acte d'engagement qu'en crédit
de paiement
ce programme 112
doit avoir la mise en oeuvre des
contrats de plan est en région inter
région pour 2021 2027 des CPE et leur
voler territoriale je veux rappeler ici
l'importance de ces contrats qui doivent
s'inscrire dans une logique ascendante
de partenariat
de dialogue entre les collectivités
locales et l'État et aussi de
décentralisation bien évidemment qui
doivent traduire une stratégie globale
d'aménagement et non une addition de
projet
28 milliards d'euros de crédit d'État
ont été contractualisés dans les CPER et
CPIE er pour la 7e génération de contrat
dont un peu moins d'un milliards pour le
volet très territorial
un mot sur le contexte et l'impact à
craindre pour les dépenses
d'investissement des collectivités
locales dernièrement les magistrats
financiers
prévoyez que la situation
à la fin de l'année ne serait pas
certainement pas meilleur qu'en 2021 or
depuis quelques mois quelques semaines
les collectivités navigue à vue
songer qu'au début du mois d'octobre
Bercy estimée dans une autre
confidentielle rendue publique depuis
que l'année 2022 s'achèvera sans
difficulté pour les collectivités et
envisagez même des perspectives
favorables pour 2023 permettant de faire
face à l'inflation trois semaines plus
tard la Cour des Comptes est loin d'être
aussi affirmative et reste plus plutôt
prudente devant l'incertitude de liées à
la conjoncture économique actuelle dans
son rapport dernier le la juridiction de
la rue Cambon révèle la dégradation
rapide de la situation
en raison bien évidemment de l'inflation
des coups de service et des biens de la
difficulté de mettre en oeuvre des
projets d'investissement et aussi
tradition ne se problème de
multiplication de ces problèmes de
l'aggravation des appels d'offres
infructueux ces contraintes s'ajoutent
aux inéluctables dépenses contraintes
telles que le point d'indice la
revalorisation des catégories C ou les
rénovations énergétiques auxquelles sont
confrontées et collectivités locales
dans ce contexte vous y comprend bien et
on mesure aujourd'hui sur le terrain
combien cela complique fortement la
capacité des collectivités locales à
lancer des opérations d'investissement
un mot sur la NCT
ZRR les crédits inscrits dans la mg23
sont stables pour la NCT mais notre
rapporteur a indiqué les difficultés
financières de celle-ci pour financer
les simples dépenses de fonctionnement
et sa difficulté à financer l'émission
qui sont confiées au fil de l'eau par
l'État et pour intervenir à la demande
de ses partenaires
notre rapport note également au passage
le manque de coopération entre les
différents opérateurs partenaires que
sont le serment
l'agence l'entru Lana l'Agence nationale
pour la maîtrise de l'énergie et la
Caisse des dépôts est consignations par
le BI des conventions la révision
programmée de ces conventions qui
arrivent à terme
devrait être l'occasion justement de
rechercher une lumière cohérence comme
nous l'avions craint ici même lors de la
discussion sur la création de la NCT
c'était établissement public manque
d'une stratégie globale construite avec
les opérateurs et souffrent
d'une réelle visibilité combien d'élus
encore
ignorent même son existence et ou une
partie de ces missions autre sujet la
maison des Francs services qui est
aujourd'hui en phase de stabilisation
les objectifs finitions de ce point de
vue ont été relativement atteints que ce
soit en termes de son maillage
territorial je note que lorsque
justement la logique à s'entente est
respectée le résultat est plutôt
satisfaisant globalement 2600 structures
labellisées à ce jour dans les deux
tiers à l'initiative des collectivités
locales constituent une offre réelle de
service de proximité auquel il s'ajoute
quand même les 127 buts francs services
dépoli à ce jour qui doivent traduire
véritablement la volonté de l'État
d'aller au devant des administrés dans
les coins les plus éloignés des services
et vers ceux qui n'ont pas basculé vers
le digital trop souvent présenté comme
la panacée et une évidence nous pouvons
ainsi aussi nous inspirer notre du
rapporteur Delcros sur le financement
des réseaux francs services je pense que
ce sera une occasion d'en parler un
dernier mot sur la remise alpha des
zonage et sur la tractivité au
développement rural je pense que à la
dynamisation du dispositif des aides
derrière pour toutes ces raisons
monsieur le ministre nous nous
abstiendrons sur cette mission merci
chers collègues la parole est à Madame
Martine filleul pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
pour 4 minutes
le président
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues alors de l'urgence du
changement climatique et des lourdes
contraintes qui pèse sur les finances
des collectivités nous nous interrogeons
sur la vision du gouvernement en matière
de politique d'aménagement en effet la
politique des territoires est à
reconstruire pour fonder les bases de
nouvelles solidarités territoriales
mettre en place des financements
pérennes et mieux associer les élus et
les populations dans les choix
politiques et structurants qui engagent
l'avenir de leur territoire les
collectivités territoriales ont un rôle
majeur à jouer pour répondre à ces
enjeux et en particulier ceux de la
transition écologique et offrir des
opportunités perspectives nouvelles aux
citoyens chacun doit pouvoir s'y
retrouver pour cela elles ont besoin
d'une plus grande autonomie d'actions de
mettre en place des stratégies tutorial
de déployer des actions d'animation des
acteurs de leur territoire d'organiser
le débat avec les habitants or le chemin
qui est pris n'est pas le bon entre les
injonctions contradictoires le passage
en force la pression sur les finances
locales les collectivités perdent leurs
moyens et de se fait leur pouvoir d'agir
je prends pour exemple le zan qui est
éloquant en l'état c'est un objectif
contraignant non concerté sans outil
pour le mettre en oeuvre laissant les
collectivités démunies et suscitant
l'incompréhension des populations or les
moyens de la NCT dédié ou soutien des
collectivités territoriales et à leur
accompagnement en matière d'ingénierie
non pas évolué depuis sa création
l'indicateur du programme relatif au
soutien des collectivités en demande
d'ingénierie fait apparaître une cible
de 500 projets 2023 accompagnée en
propre et sur mesure par des services ou
programmes de la NCT et 250 projets
impliquant un prestataire
issu du contrat cadre d'ingénierie ce
nombre paraît vraiment bien faire on
regarde des 25000 communes de moins de
2000 habitants potentiellement concernés
le constat est le même pour les
programmes actions cœur de ville ou
petite ville de demain par ailleurs les
services publics axes structurants de
l'aménagement du territoire se doivent
de répondre à la forte demande des
habitants des territoires ruraux mais
aussi de certains territoires
urbains or leur axe leur accessibilité
et percutée de plein fouet par la
dématérialisation de ces services
publics 14 millions de Français sont
touchés par l'électronisme et un
Français sur deux n'est pas à l'aise
avec le numérique sans compter ceux qui
n'ont pas accès à Internet et au
matériel nécessaire déjà en 2020 la
Défenseur des droits dénonçait cette
fracture numérique et recommandée de
maintenir une alternative humaine au
tout numérique car la dématérialisation
accélérée des services publics
alimentent le malaise démocratique et le
sentiment d'abandon les espaces France
services sont encore bien loin de
répondre à cette attente je conclurai
donc en disant que décidément la
politique d'aménagement proposée n'est
pas à la hauteur de cette période aux
enjeux tant de transition écologique que
de justice territoriale je vous remercie
merci chers collègue la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Claude Anglard pour le
groupe les républicains pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre monsieur les rapporteurs
chers collègues le budget de la mission
cohésion des territoires et ces
différents programmes programmes
comportent des insuffisances certaines
ce dont ceux qui ont déjà souligné les
rapporteurs dont je salue le travail
je ne suis pas loin de partager le
constat sévère des associations d'élus
concernant ce budget qui révèle un
manque de cohérence et de vision du
gouvernement concernant la politique des
territoires
le point le plus symptomatique de cette
situation
et cela a été rappelé et certainement le
budget de l'Agence nationale de la
cohésion des territoires qui est très
largement insuffisant au regard de ses
missions
la NCT devrait être acteur essentiel de
la décentralisation avec des solutions
sur mesure du coup humain adapté à la
diversité des territoires mais ces
moyens de fonctionnement sont limités en
effet ce budget ne semble pas prendre en
compte l'augmentation des nombreux
programmes pilotés par l'agence parmi
lesquels action coeur de ville
territoire d'industrie petite ville de
main ni la montée en puissance ses
programmes ce budget ne compte pas non
plus le déficit de personnel de l'agence
qui devient donc structurels le
développement de la NCT souffre de cette
situation
comment justifier que les moyens alloués
au programme France service qui servent
à combler la disparition des services
publics dans de trop nombreux
territoires soit largement en dessous de
ce que préconise l'inspection générale
de l'administration dans son rapport de
juin 2021
est-ce encore une fois aux collectivités
de compenser les carences de l'État il
n'en reste pas moins que selon moi la
première maison France service reste la
mairie dans chaque commune
plus largement ce budget a de quoi
renforcer l'inquiétude des élus des
territoires ruraux en particulier qui ne
font part de leur incompréhension
relatives à la mise en oeuvre de
politiques publiques bien souvent menées
sans eux je pense à ce qui a été fait
dans le passé dans la loi maptam dans la
loi nôtre et reversement de la taxe
aménagement et maintenant à
l'application du zan je partage
d'ailleurs le réquisitoire que nous a
livré Stéphane sotarin tout à l'heure
pour les zones rurales pour les zones
montagnes et pour l'agriculture
et dire que nous faisons toute notre
confiance à Jean-Baptiste blanc dans sa
mission et dans le rapport qu'il va
rendre dans quelques jours
indépendamment du niveau je pense aussi
pardon aux dotations d'investissement
classique DETR et des cils
indépendamment du niveau d'ouverture de
crédit dont je note qu'ils n'ont qu'il
n'augmente pas malgré l'inflation je
rappelle le gouvernement que les
collectivités n'ont pas besoin
d'injonctions particulières
écologique en 2023 pour présenter les
projets vertueux adaptés à leur
territoire le gouvernement à l'État
doivent faire confiance aux élus locaux
l'inquiétude réelle elle résulte
certainement d'une forme
d'incompréhension entre les élus locaux
et le gouvernement comme l'a montré
encore l'absence de discours du
président de la République à la tribune
de l'Association des maires de France
lors du congrès la semaine dernière
ce budget ne permet pas non plus de
dissiper les inquiétudes sur le
dispositif des zones de revitalisation
rurale que nous souhaitons voir ce
poursuivre et ce dispositif a montré son
efficacité et le Sénat bien sûr devra
être associé à son éventuel réforme il
ne donne pas non plus de visibilité sur
la poursuite de la gendar rurale même si
nous avons noté le travail engagé et
qu'à rappeler notre collègue Bernard
delcro ce budget traduit une période de
flottement pour la ruralité alors qu'il
aurait pu révéler enfin la vision du
gouvernement a cours ou à long terme la
cohésion des territoires nécessite une
prise en compte des spécificités pour
forger une armature territoriale de
proximité fondée sur la commune avec des
élus qui peuvent réellement exercer une
compétence
enfin mes doutes concernent le budget ce
budget sont renforcés par le contexte
économique actuel donc finalement et
pour terminer est-ce que la cohésion du
territoire qu'est-ce que la cohésion du
territoire pour 2023
la parole est à monsieur le Président
Claude Malhuret pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 5 minutes
madame la présidente madame et monsieur
le ministre monsieur les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues la cohésion des
territoires est un noble dessin il
reporte sur la certitude que l'immense
diversité de ce qui fait la France et la
force de notre pays cette ambition
engage l'État à faire confiance à
l'échelon local ces élus et ses acteurs
de terrain elle engage également l'état
à leur donner les moyens nécessaires
pour agir
des crédits du volet cohésion du
territoire du PLF 2023 bénéficie de 17,9
milliards d'euros dont 329 millions
d'euros destinés à la politique des
territoires c'est considérable parmi les
différents programmes de la mission
l'Agence nationale de cohésion
territoriale apporte un soutien en
ingénierie aux collectivités et les
accompagne dans le déploiement de leurs
projets de territoire depuis sa création
notre groupe souligne la pertinence de
cet outil au service des élus locaux en
particulier dans les territoires ruraux
le PLF pour 2023 attribue à la NCT une
dotation équivalente à celle des années
précédentes on parle de 20 millions
d'euros au titre du budget ingénierie
pourtant la NCT a atteint la plupart de
ses objectifs et son cahier des charges
a été progressivement élargi il est
dommage que ce PLF n'a juste pas les
dotations de la NCT à l'ampleur de ses
missions les prochains mois seront je
l'espère l'occasion d'engager une
réflexion sur le futur
de cet agence
je salue la poursuite de politique
ambitieuse en faveur des petites villes
et des espaces ruraux le programme
petite ville de demain par exemple
permet à 1600 communes de bénéficier de
moyens supplémentaires ce sont les élus
eux-mêmes qui définissent leur priorités
et qui pilotent leurs projets c'est une
bonne approche qui permet aux habitants
d'être mobilisés au même titre que les
entreprises les élus les professionnels
et l'ensemble des acteurs du territoire
près de 2200 espaces France services
mailles l'ensemble du territoire
national et permettent de maintenir une
offre de service public de proximité ces
maisons aident réellement les Français
jusque dans les territoires les moins
faciles d'accès grâce à des bus
itinérants le PLF leur consacre 36,3
millions d'euros pour 2023 c'est une
bonne nouvelle car cette politique a du
sens en revanche si nous voulons que les
politiques en faveur de l'attractivité
des territoires ruraux soient couronnés
de succès il faut résorber les zones
blanches en matière de numérique et de
réseau mobile les conseillers numériques
France servent accompagnent
accomplissent un formidable travail au
quotidien c'est un point souligné mais
cela n'est pas suffisant les élus locaux
dont nous sommes les porte-voix nous
sollicitent régulièrement en ce sens
chacun doit avoir accès à un réseau 4G
et à une connexion internet de qualité
car c'est une condition essentielle au
développement de nos territoires l'État
doit être mobilisé pour endiguer les
fractures d'usage numérique et d'accès
au réseau
nous pourrons d'ailleurs nous interroger
sur les dotations dont dispose la NCT en
la matière comme le souhaitait ma
collègue le sénateur VANITA pas lui Gaja
trop de territoires restent encore
aujourd'hui à l'écart des différents
dispositifs
concernant la politique en faveur de
l'hébergement et de l'accès au logement
notre groupe s'inquiète des tensions sur
les prix nous appelons également à
intensifier les efforts en matière de
rénovation thermique du parc immobilier
existant le contexte inflationniste
souligne l'urgence des dispositifs en
matière de lutte contre la précarité
énergétique nous serons attentifs à la
mise en oeuvre opérationnelle du fond
vert
et à sa distribution
au sujet de la politique de la ville les
crédits sont annoncés à hauteur de 600
millions d'euros environ je salue la
hausse du budget car les chantiers sont
importants nous pouvons toutefois nous
inquiéter de la baisse des moyens
relatifs à l'éducation dans la quartier
de la politique de la ville
l'État ne doit pas laisser faiblir son
ambition en la matière
enfin la poursuite du programme Action
cœur de ville va dans le bon sens tant
il apporte des solutions au défi de la
revitalisation et du verdissement des
villes moyennes l'État doit s'appuyer
sur les territoires ruraux commurbain
qui sont des moteurs en matière de
transition écologique la relation
partenariale qui s'incarne notamment par
la contractualisation dans les contrats
plans état région va dans le bon sens le
groupe Les Indépendants accueille
favorablement ses crédits cohésion des
territoires tout en appelant à
poursuivre les dispositifs de soutien en
faveur de l'échelon local
les élus connaissent leur territoire ces
enjeux ses habitants ils sont en mesure
de concrétiser l'alliance de l'écologie
et du développement économique local
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Klein ministre délégué
chargé de la ville et du logement et
pour 15 minutes
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je suis heureux
de présenter la mission cohésion des
territoires dans le cadre du projet de
loi de finances pour 2023 et je
commencerai par vous parler de la
politique du logement
cette politique du logement ne doit bien
sûr pas minimiser les difficultés du
secteur difficulté de la demande avec
l'enjeu de solvabilité des ménages
l'accès au crédit
difficulté liées à l'offre alors qui
existe d'importants freins à la
construction
face à cela nous nous donnons les moyens
de nos ambitions
à travers ce budget ma priorité c'est
d'abord le parcours résidentiel
ce parcours résidentiel concerne d'abord
ceux qui n'ont pas de logement le mal
logement et le sans-abrisme sont des
fléaux contre lesquels nous luttons tous
les jours avec des résultats
la politique d'hébergement et d'accès au
logement des personnes sans abri ou mal
logés soutenues par le programme 177
vise à permettre l'accès au logement
tout en garantissant une réponse aux
situations d'urgence
le parc d'hébergements financé par
l'État à atteint un niveau inédit de
plus de 203000 places ouvertes en 2021
dans le contexte de la crise sanitaire
en 2023 à l'issue des changes fructueux
avec les associations les préfectures et
les parlementaires
ayant abouti un amendement à l'Assemblée
nationale les capacités d'accueil du
parc seront maintenues à un niveau élevé
d'environ 197000 places
le projet de loi de finances date pour
cela le programme 177 à hauteur de 2,8
milliards d'euros un niveau jamais
atteint et je peux vous assurer mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs que l'État
agit et l'État est très réceptif
au delà de l'hébergement d'urgence la
priorité d'offrir une solution de
logement pérenne à chacun le plan
logement d'abord initié par le Président
de la République il y a 5 ans
avec ce plan ce sont 400 000 personnes
qui ont pu accéder à un logement de
passer de la rue à un toit
nous poursuivons nos efforts avec un
nouveau plan logement d'abord
44 millions d'euros supplémentaires ils
seront consacrés dès 2023
défendre le parcours résidentiel c'est
permettre à chacun selon sa situation
d'accéder à un logement décent et d'ici
maintenir durablement
le programme 109 aide à l'accès au
logement finance les aides accordées aux
personnes en difficulté en 2023 ce
programme est de T de 13,4 milliards
d'euros en aidant les médailles aux
ressources modestes et en les
accompagnant dans leur démarche ce
programme participe à la mise en œuvre
du droit au logement prévu par la loi
DALO de 2007 toujours au bénéfice du
parcours résidentiel ma mission est
aussi de celle de construire plus et
construire mieux
le programme 135 porte à cette fin la
stratégie gouvernementale en matière de
politique du logement et d'aménagement
cette stratégie repose sur les piliers
suivants
construire mieux et moins cher en
accélérant le rythme de construction
notamment en zone tendue en simplifiant
l'acte de construire
accélérer la rénovation et améliorer le
niveau de performance énergétique des
logements
avec la politique de sobriété
énergétique dans le logement avec le
calendrier des radications des passoires
thermiques et avec ma prime rénov nous
avons fait sauter un premier verrou en
installant la culture écologique la
culture de l'éco-geste dans les foyers
c'est un premier acquis précieux et
beaucoup d'entre vous l'ont souligné
tout au long de nos premiers échanges
mais soyons lucides la rénovation
thermique n'en est si j'ose dire qu'à
son âge adolescent ce quinquennat doit
nous permettre de passer à l'âge adulte
passer du monogèse à la rénovation
performante passez de l'individuel aux
collectif passé de la structuration
d'une filière naissante à la
consolidation d'une filière puissante et
nous nous en donnons les moyens
le PLF 2023 prévoit
2,45 milliards d'euros sur le dispositif
socle ma prime rénov financé par le
programme 174 qui sera discuté cet
après-midi et un renforcement sur le
programme 135 des moyens de Lana en
faveur notamment de la rénovation
énergétique pour consolider la dynamique
inédite lancée dans la relance
notre accélération se traduira
par un meilleur accompagnement des
ménages à travers le service public
France Renov par la poursuite du soutien
aux copropriété de tout type l'aide ma
prime rénov copropriété sera prolongée
pour accentuer l'effort de rénovation
des logements en collectif et nous
travaillerons à l'accompagnement des
copropriétés toutes les copropriétés
un mot
ça a été évoqué aussi s'agissant de
l'adaptation des logements au grand âge
et de la promesse de campagne du
président de la République de lancer ma
primadapt une aide unique simple et
attractive
c'est évidemment l'une de mes priorités
et le budget que je défends doit
permettre à l'ANA un quasi doublement du
nombre de logements adaptés l'année
prochaine pour amorcer la dynamique se
concrétisera par le lancement de la
nouvelle aide en 2024
en matière de logements social ce projet
de loi de finances préserve le modèle de
financement du secteur qui fait face à
des objectifs ambitions
prolongation des avantages fiscaux la
TFPB stabilité de l'ARS
la contribution d'Action Logement au
Fnac Front national d'aide à la pierre
que vous avez supprimé constitue à mon
sens un élément essentiel de cette
équilibre les discussions se
poursuivront bien sûr pour renouveler la
convention quinquennale et assurer
collectivement le bon financement du
secteur en parallèle des travaux pour
conclure impact essentiel de confiance
avec l'ensemble des acteurs du logement
social
ça a été évoqué aussi mon ministère
n'est pas que celui du logement c'est
aussi celui de la ville et des quartiers
populaires la politique de la ville
intervient dans 1514 quartiers
prioritaire où vivent plus de 5,5
millions de nos concitoyens elle fédère
l'ensemble des acteurs qui concourent
l'État les collectivités les
associations et bien sûr les habitants
permettez-moi à ce moment de souligner
l'excellent travail du rapport des
sénatrices validir il est tard Dominique
Estrosi Sassone et Viviane Artigalas qui
seront un outil très précieux de la
réflexion sur les nouveaux contrats de
ville
les crédits de la politique de la ville
regroupés au sein du programme 147 et
les agences nationales pour la
rénovation urbaine jouent un effet de
levier indispensable pour réduire les
écarts de développement entre les
quartiers et les autres territoires et
améliorer les conditions de vie des
habitants
pour 2023 la politique de la ville fait
l'objet de nouveaux efforts ces crédits
viennent pérenniser notre action dans
les quartiers avec l'opération quartier
d'été et les autres opérations dans
d'autres budgets mais vacances
apprenantes notamment qui seront des
éléments essentiels dans nos quartiers
dès l'été prochain
renforcer aussi la présence humaine dans
les quartiers avec les adultes relais
prolonger comme ça a été indiqué les
cités éducatives et comme la souligner
madame la sénatrice avait
enfin bien évidemment poursuivre le
financement du nouveau programme de
renouvellement
urbain au total ce sont 37,2 milliards
d'euros de contributions total des
ministères concernés
nous voulons aller plus loin en apporte
en portant l'ambition quartier 2030
annoncé par le président de la
République dont les nouveaux contrats de
ville seront l'outil et le chemin en
donnant la parole aux habitants en
reconnaissant leur place dans la
République nous construirons des
quartiers qui donnent le pouvoir d'en
partir mais surtout l'envie d'y rester
enfin
la mission porte également les crédits
en matière d'impulsion et de
coordination de la politique
d'aménagement du territoire
le programme 112 qui représente 262
millions d'euros pour l'année 2023 a
pour ambition d'accompagner tous les
territoires dans les grandes transitions
et leur donner les moyens afin
d'aménagement durable
de notre pays et de lutter efficacement
contre les fractures territoriales
ces crédits en hausse de 6% par rapport
à l'année 2022 concours à la réalisation
de trois objectifs principaux
apporter des moyens renforcés à l'Agence
nationale de la cohésion des territoires
la NTT afin d'assurer un meilleur appui
auprès des collectivités
accompagner aussi les grandes
transformations territoriales au travers
du déploiement de programme d'appui
spécifique ces programmes vous les
connaissez vous les avez cités ce sont
francs service petite ville de demain
territoire d'industrie nouveau lieu
nouveau lien action cœur de ville agenda
rural ou encore le plan France très haut
débit
enfin inscrire avec l'État dans la durée
grâce au contrat de plan état région
co-père et au contrat de relance de
transition écologique ces nouveaux
contrats territoriaux représente une
avancée
car plus réelle globaux et passer et
basé sur une approche une approche
différenciée en fonction des régions
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ces
programmes sont essentiels pour nos
concitoyens
essentiels pour notre territoire partout
sur notre territoire pour ces raisons je
vous invite à voter ces crédits je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le Ministre
alors nous allons procéder à l'examen
des amendements portant sur les crédits
de la mission cohésion des territoires
figurant à l'état B
et de suite je vais vous redonner la
parole monsieur le ministre pour
l'amendement 1218 du gouvernement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
le gouvernement vous propose un
amendement important pour abonder les
crédits d'un peu plus de 30 millions
d'euros pour les métiers de la branche
action sanitaire et sociale conformément
aux annonces et de la première ministre
et du ministre des Solidarités c'est
abondement et l'équivalent de la hausse
du point d'indice de 3,5% intervenu pour
la fonction publique et qu'il est
important de faire profiter aussi
l'ensemble des métiers de la branche
action sanitaire et sociale
voilà
très bien
la vie de la Commission
s Centre d'hébergement de réinsertion
sociale centre d'hébergement d'urgence
et de très nombreuses structures et
associations qui participent à mettre en
avant une politique publique et paraît
approprié pour la pour la commission de
le reconnaître en finançant cette
revalorisation précisée par le ministre
sera un avis favorable merci alors je
vais mettre aux voix donc l'amendement
du Gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient et donc
adopter la maman 1058 madame Artigalas
monsieur boide
demande de retrait merci
le 1063 madame Artigalas
merci madame la Présidente après la
crise sanitaire les ménages modestes
sont de nouveau fragilisés par la
flambée des prix de l'énergie cette
situation met en lumière à la nécessité
d'accélérer la rénovation énergétique en
favoris priorisant les ménages précaires
avec la mise en place d'un zéro reste à
charge il faut favoriser des travaux
plus ambitieux pour qu'on fait on
perçoivent les signes concrets d'une
transition énergétique encore trop
inefficace encore trop inégalitaire 3,5
millions de foyers soit près de 18% de
la population sont concernés par la
précarité et l'exclusion énergétique en
France rappelons qu'il y a par ailleurs
urgence les logements les plus
énergivores vont disparaître
progressivement du marché de la location
pour les logements en classe G cette
interdiction entre en vigueur au 1er
janvier 2023 or 85% des chantiers
financés par Lana concerne encore des
opérations monogestes ne permettant ni
réduire la précarité énergétique ni
d'être efficace dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique trop peu de
personnes s'engagent dans un parcours de
rénovation globale les raisons en sont
simples près de la moitié des ménages
résidant en passant thermique ont des
faibles revenus et 62 % ont plus de 60
ans ma prime rénove sérénité l'aide pour
les ménages aurait source très modeste
et financée par le budget de Lana et
soutient les rénovations conduisant un
gain énergétique minimal de 35%. notre
amendement propose de renforcer cette
aide pour réorienter massivement
l'action de l'ANAH vers les logements
classés fog via mécanisme d'aide
complémentaire qui permettent une
rénovation globale et en reste à charge
zéro
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
madame la Présidente est en effet
toujours souhaitable de favoriser des
rénovations globales toutefois madame la
sénatrice j'ai rencontré la directrice
générale de la narna qui n'a pas formulé
une telle demande de crédit
supplémentaire et qui a surtout souligné
et je partage ce constat la difficulté
que nous avons face à nous qui est celle
de l'absence de véritable écosystème
d'entreprise générale capable de
réaliser des rénovations globales pour
le parc privé c'est aussi la difficulté
pour les particuliers d'organiser de
tels travaux en tant que que mettre
d'ouvrage donc à ce stade notre histoire
c'est un avis de retrait sinon
défavorable merci David du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice vous avez raison la rénovation
thermique
de l'habitat individuel comme de
l'habitat collectif est une priorité que
nous partageons le ma prime rénov
sérénité donc la partie qui est de les
ménages les plus modestes et a déjà
atteint un budget de plus de 500
millions d'euros il a été augmenté en
2023 de 130 millions d'euros dans le
cadre des aides préalable plus de 80%
des ménages qui ont été aidés par ma
prime manœuvre sont des ménages modestes
mais comme ça a été dit par Monsieur le
Président
à ce stade la filière n'est pas prête et
surtout le nombre de dossiers qui
arriverait ne correspondrait pas à une
augmentation aussi importante de cette
demande je peux vous assurer de notre
mobilisation la mobilisation de
l'ensemble des services celle de Lana
pour accompagner la demande pour
accompagner tout à la fois les ménages
les plus en difficulté qu'ils soient en
copropriété où en est en habitat
individuel mais à ce stade nous vous
proposons plutôt un retrait sinon ça
sera un avis défavorable car cette
augmentation d'autant plus gagée sur le
177 ne nous paraît pas au portant merci
merci Madame linman
notre groupe soutiendra l'amendement de
du groupe socialiste et de Madame
Artigalas pourquoi bien sûr en l'état
actuel on va pas brutalement pouvoir
faire zéro char zéro reste à charge sur
tout ce dont on aurait besoin de
d'engager pour atteindre l'éradication
des passeurs thermiques néanmoins la
question de la des réhabilitation
globale pour ces ménages là est une
question centrale donc il serait quand
même important qu'on puisse au moins à
titre expérimental sur un nombre par
exemple limité contingenté d'opérations
de tester l'idée du Zéro reste à charge
avec un complément de Lana parce que si
cette méthode marche
ça prouve bien que on atteindra pas les
objectifs de la loi climat énergie sans
ce travail majeur sur le reste à charge
des familles modestes et fermer d'un
revers de main l'opportunité de
commencer à s'engager dans cette voie
nous par une erreur alors oui la filière
il y a un problème enfin on va attendre
combien de temps d'avoir résolu le
problème de la filière alors qu'on a des
exigences qui sont fixées par la loi à
des délais maintenant rapides et c'est
un peu le serpent qui se mord la queue
c'est à dire s'il y a pas d'obligation
de faire des travaux il y a pas assez de
travaux pour développer la filière et si
la filière n'est pas suffisante on dit
qu'on peut pas faire les travaux donc
nous soutiendrons cet amendement merci
Madame Martigues
oui je vais retirer cette amendement
parce que effectivement la ligne
budgétaire sur lequel on prend les
crédits ne me paraît pas être voilà mais
c'est vraiment un amendement d'appel je
crois que Madame Liman a raison on est
vraiment dans une situation où des
logements vont sortir du marché très
rapidement et puis des personnes qui
sont en précarité énergétique il faut
vraiment travailler à ce zéro reste à
charge et bien évidemment aussi à la
réorganisation de la filière je suis
d'accord avec le avec le rapporteur mais
bon je le retire mais vraiment c'est un
sujet qu'il faut absolument regarder de
très très près et très rapidement
si chers collègues la maman 1082 madame
linemann
défendu
il défendu merci la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
si la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
un avis de retrait ou des favorable
comme le rapporteur
merci mamie
c'est amendement concrétis ce que j'ai
expliqué en déclaration générale à
savoir quand même la faiblesse du
forfait charge auront ce qu'il a ses
dépenses de chauffage et de charge vont
continuer à peser lourdement s'il y a
pas des cette année une amélioration de
ce forfait au-delà des deux euros on va
durablement et dans un décalage entre
l'évolution des aPL est-ce que les
foyers doivent payer dans leur quittance
donc nous avons proposé un abonnement de
500 millions pour ce chapitre je
rappelle un million un milliard 5 tous
les ans économisés par la mise en oeuvre
de la contemporainéité donc on a
pénalisé les plus pauvres pour alors que
là on aurait pu au moins redistribuer
cette somme
alors je mets aux voix là mon 1082 qui a
reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopter madame Lindeman pour le 1084
l'idée c'est de on a discuté longtemps
notamment du prélèvement d'axi au
logement etc du Fnac il y a nous sommes
défavorables à la RLS je rappelle que la
Cour des comptes avait fait un rapport
montrant que l'instauration de la RLS
fragilisait dans la durée les capacités
désorganismes HLM à construire et à
rénover et donc nous proposons de
réduire l'air et laisse déjà au moins de
300 millions d'euros
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
madame la Présidente il se trouve que un
nouveau pacte de confiance doit être
négocié dans les mois à venir entre les
acteurs du logement il est trop tôt pour
que la loi intervienne d'autant que le
problème n'est pas immédiat les
organismes de logement social sont dans
leur grande majorité dans une situation
saine et l'enjeu et de faire en sorte
qu'ils puissent continuer à investir à
rénover leur parc dans les années et
décennies à venir
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
oui
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
vous votre abonnement évoque une baisse
de la RLS comme ça vient d'être dit par
monsieur le rapporteur c'est ce sont des
débats qui doivent être engagés dans le
cas de d'une réflexion plus large sur le
financement du logement social et bien
évidemment dans le cadre du pacte de
confiance en l'état des choses moi je
crois qu'il faut bien évidemment
continuer à financer le snap dans la
situation actuelle le financement tel
qu'il est proposé par Action Logement
correspond à un état des échanges que
nous avons avec eux et de toute façon
pour ma part la proposition qui avait
été celle d'Action Logement qui était un
basculement un vaste communicant entre
le financement du Fnac par Action
Logement en faisant financer le snap par
les bailleurs n'était pas la bonne
solution donc il faut continuer à
échanger aujourd'hui et les capacités et
du d'ailleurs d'une certaine manière
j'aimerais beaucoup qu'on dépense la
totalité de l'argent inscrite au Fnac
qui montrerait la réelle dynamique que
l'on aurait partout pour construire plus
de logements malheureusement depuis
quelques années la totalité de l'argent
inscrit au snap n'a pas été dépensé donc
à ce stade je vous propose ou un retrait
ou un avis défavorable merci Monsieur
ministre mamie
sur la consommation des crédits du Fnac
par les organismes HLM je rappelle que
il y a un décalage souvent entre les
orientations données par l'État qui
privilégie la réalisation de pls et la
mobilisation du Fnac il faut massivement
orienter la production vers du plus et
du P l'ai c'est à dire du logement a
pris beaucoup plus abordable et engagé
une meilleure
un meilleur engagement du snap pour cela
mais je partage votre point de vue
monsieur le ministre l'argent doit être
dépensé ça sert à rien de le laisser
dans les caisses pour des jours
meilleurs je l'espère néanmoins votre
argumentaire monsieur le rapporteur que
je peux comprendre sur faut attendre le
pack de confiance mais le pack de
confiance il dépendra de ce que il y a
dans les inscriptions budgétaires parce
que dès cette année on va avoir un
problème
d'abondement de l'aide à la pierre dès
cette année notre
devrait donner un signe politique d'une
résorption progressive de la RLS qui
pénalise les HLM
merci alors je mets aux voix donc la
maman 1084 qui a reçu
excusez-moi
non je voulais insister sur cette
question de la relation effectivement je
suis d'accord avec Marie-Noël lilleman
cette RLS elle a aussi beaucoup pénalisé
les bailleurs sociaux dans la
construction de logements et ça va
continuer donc si on prend une attaque
pas ce problème dès maintenant par cette
amendement
d'appel pour dire que le problème est là
il faut revenir sur cette RLS
merci alors je mets aux voix même la
présidente l'état oui madame la
Présidente très brièvement mais juste
pour rejoindre mes deux collègues même
si on sait que c'est un amendement
d'appel vu l'affectation des crédits on
est tous bien d'accord mais c'est vrai
que cette RLS LP naliste tout
additionnons à ça effectivement les
modalités d'amendement du Fnac qui ne
sont pas satisfaisantes parce
qu'effectivement direction logement on
préfère que ce soit les bailleurs qui
financent c'est quand même moyen le Fnac
à l'origine elle est quand même abondé
par l'État et l'État pourrait prendre sa
part dans le financement des politiques
du logement mais évidemment qu'il faut
revoir la RLS est très très rapidement
sans attendre l'exercice budgétaire
prochain
merci alors je mets aux voix donc
l'amende mon 1084 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre
le verbe les mains je sais que c'est le
fin de matinée alors je vais recommencer
qui est pour
qui contre
alors deux amendements de discussion
comme une le 1062 madame Martigues
merci beaucoup amendement 1077 madame
linman
même un rendement et comme je viens de
le dire notre collègue nous l'avions
voté la suppression de ce mois de
carence à l'unanimité à l'occasion de la
PPL proposé par notre groupe merci la
vie de la Commission sur ces deux
amendements sur le rapporteur
madame la Présidente sont des
amendements qui auraient un coup élevé
250 millions et d'autre part n'est pas
sûr que leur mise en œuvre soit aisée
notamment parce que cela suppose une
modification des systèmes d'information
et en toute état de cause il s'agirait
de mieux définir les
conditions les conditions des aides qui
sont qui sont versées telles que l'avait
prévu le Sénat en 2020 à travers une
proposition de loi qui supprimait ce
mois de carence
si la vidéo gouvernement chez le
ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice monsieur le sénateur
effectivement vous vous proposez de
supprimer le mois de carence à
l'attribution de l'aide au logement
d'abord ce mois de carence n'est pas
propre aux apl c'est une règle
permettant de vérifier dans l'ensemble
des prestations sociales
[Musique]
l'étude du dossier et éviter des
versements indus ou des rappels
néanmoins vous le savez dans un certain
nombre de cas il n'y a pas ce mois de
carence lorsqu'il y a un déménagement
lorsqu'il y a une personne qui passe
d'une résidence sociale à un habitat
pérenne et dans un certain nombre de cas
d'urgence ces mesures de de carence
n'existent pas et comme l'a rappelé le
rapporteur à ce stade cette mesure
aurait un coût très important prix gagé
sur le programme 177 et donc pour ces
raisons j'aimais un avis défavorable
merci alors je mets aux voix
l'amendement 1062 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient donc il n'est pas adopté
le 1077 même avis même vote merci
alors deux amendements discussion
commune le 391 oui merci madame la
Présidente selon un rapport de la
Fondation des femmes de 2021 titré où
est l'argent pour l'hébergement des
femmes victimes de violence il est noté
que souvent pour faire cesser les
violences la seule solution pour les
femmes et la décohabitation or le
rapport note que près de 40% des femmes
victimes de violence dont un tiers avait
confond qui ont demandé un hébergement
n'ont pas obtenu de solution 4 demandes
sur 10 n'ont pas été suivies d'une mise
à l'abri les spécialistes des
associations et des services publics
dédiés aux violences sexistes et
sexuelles dont le Haut Conseil à
l'égalité estime à un milliard d'euros
les moyens nécessaires à la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes selon le
même rapport de la Fondation des femmes
000 femmes ont besoin d'un hébergement
d'urgence et d'après le rapport
d'information de la délégation droit des
femmes n'ont pas d'ici mais de
l'Assemblée nationale sur le PLF 2023 le
nombre total de places d'hébergement
pour les femmes victimes de violences
conjugales atteindraient aujourd'hui
11000 enfin 11000 11000 places à la fin
2023 même pas aujourd'hui il manque donc
9000 places d'hébergement d'urgence le
coût approximatif d'une place au CHRS
étant de 18000 euros simple règle de 3
c'est amendement se propose d'investir
162 millions d'euros supplémentaires
pour qu'il n'y ait plus quatre femmes
sur 10 qui demandent en vain un abri
d'urgence j'invite tous mes collègues
solennellement sur tous les bancs à
voter cet amendement pour réduire un peu
le retard de la France dans le combat
contre les violences conjugales et de
fait ensuite puisque nous allons le
voter j'espère s'invite le gouvernement
à lever le gage
merci
le 1053 monsieur gold oui merci madame
la Présidente dans le même état d'esprit
que l'argumentaire de précédent nous
finissons donc l'année avec 102
féminicides dont une grande partie de
femmes tuées chez elles un nouveau pack
un pack nouveau départ plutôt devrait
être expérimenté dès le début de l'année
prochaine pour prévenir les faux départ
de domicile en améliorant la prise en
charge des victimes et pourrait
comprendre une proposition d'hébergement
d'urgence ce n'est pas suffisant de mon
corps de structure donc le présentement
propose la création de 1000 places
d'urgence en augmentant de 5 millions
d'euros les crédits consacrés à cette
politique merci la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
la Présidente il y a déjà une chose que
je comprends pas c'est la mécanique
c'est vieux amendements c'est à 162
millions pour le 391 pour créer 9000
places et 5 millions pour en créer 1000
je trouve ce coup étonnamment faible
mais sinon depuis plusieurs années le
compte agence spécifique place destiné à
des femmes victimes violences a été
identifiée dans le parc d'hébergement
d'urgence et j'ai noté que selon les
documents budgétaires près de 4500
places sont dédiées aux femmes victimes
de ces violences dans le parc
d'hébergement d'urgence que je viens de
mentionner et notamment en CHRS et dans
certaines autres dispositifs 418 places
seront dispositif d'aide au logement
temporaire ou LT peut-être que le
ministre pourra donner des chiffres
encore plus précis que ce que je viens
de verser au départ alors qu'allons-nous
devant nous on a un projet de loi de
finances pour 2023 qui finançait 1000
places supplémentaires sur ces
différents dispositifs donc il faut
reconnaître qu'il y a une prise de
conscience progressive et telle à la
hauteur de l'histoire évidemment c'est
c'est la question madame la sénatrice
mais on peut dire aussi que le parc
d'hébergement d'urgence n'a pas vocation
à traiter tous les cas de femmes
victimes de violence que la réponse
normale est quand même l'éviction du
conjoint violent afin que la femme
puisse rester au colissime conjugal le
parc d'hébergement d'urgence est destiné
au cas où cette réponse par défaut ne
peut pas être apportée immédiatement
donc en l'état au bénéfice ces
explications en attendant celles du
ministre ce sera un avis de retrait
sinon défavorable si la vidéo
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice monsieur le sénateur bien
évidemment la question des femmes
victimes de violence est une question
prioritaire et vous le savez du
gouvernement précédent comme de celui-ci
entre 2017 et 2022 c'est 76% de place
supplémentaires qui ont été dédiés aux
femmes victimes de violences conjugales
et à leurs enfants
j'étais moi-même il y a quelques jours
avec Isabelle borne
Elisabeth borne et Isabelle Rome dans
différents centre d'hébergement
notamment un centre de grande qualité à
Amiens la première ministre a annoncé
lors du troisième anniversaire si j'ose
dire du Grenelle des violences faites
aux femmes une augmentation de 1000
places supplémentaires pour atteindre
comme vous l'avez dit madame la
sénatrice 11000 places à la fin 2023
c'est donc 110 millions d'euros qui sera
consacré à ce parc dédié et en plus en
fonction des besoins c'est environ 1,6
millions de nuitées qui ont été financés
pendant l'année 2021 bien évidemment
cette ce drame dépasse largement la
question du nombre de places c'est une
priorité portée par le gouvernement mais
à ce stade je ne crois pas qu'il se
règle
à coups de financement mais bien de
prise en compte et de protection des
femmes victimes de violence dans le
cadre déjà existant et de celui de la
progression indiquée par la première
ministre merci même
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
ministre chers collègues juste en
réaction à ces deux amendements et en
lien aussi avec l'amendement qui portait
sur le délai de carence rappelez-vous il
y a quelques semaines de ça nous avons
adopté à l'unanimité
une proposition de loi qui visait à
l'aide d'universelle d'urgence pour les
femmes et pour toute personne d'ailleurs
victime de violences conjugales
elle sert à quoi cette PPL elle sert
juste à faire en sorte que le premier
mois quand une femme victime de violence
quitte le domicile elle va d'abord vers
l'hébergement d'urgence certes elle a
besoin qu'il y ait des places
disponibles mais surtout cette aide elle
vise à faire en sorte que et bien dans
ce mois qu'il a sépare de toutes les
aides de droit commun qui mettent un
mois à se débloquer elle n'est pas comme
seul choix de retourner au domicile du
conjoint violent et donc quand on parle
de délai de carence que je voulais dire
monsieur le ministre autant il faut
préserver des places certes autant il
faut aussi faire en sorte que dans le
délai de carence on fasse en sorte que
les femmes victimes de violence ne se
retrouvent pas dans une situation
d'emprise financière et obligée de
retourner chez le l'auteur des violences
faute d'avoir pu avoir dès le premier
jour le bénéfice de l'APL qui peut la
mettre en difficulté financière et avoir
le résultat que je viens de vous évoquer
oui merci même votre Présidente c'est
par rapport à la remarque de monsieur le
rapporteur il s'agit de la Fondation des
femmes a bien calculé les places
d'hébergement d'urgence qui était
nécessaire à côté effectivement quelques
fois du départ du du conjoint ou de la
conjointe mais c'est à 97 % un conjoint
qui lui aussi quelquefois peut être
amené plus qu'amener enfin obligé de
partir donc il s'agit bien d'une étude
des besoins au parc d'une étude des
besoins on parle pas de toutes les
solutions malheureusement c'est bien
au-delà que les les qu'il faut financer
toutes les solutions
je vous rappelle quand même qu'on de que
les associations beaucoup d'associations
demandent que 0,5 0,5% du PIB soit
consacré à ça afin que bien sûr monsieur
le ministre vous faites 1000 places par
année mais c'est un rythme insuffisant
voilà sur les quatre ceux qui n'ont pas
un hébergement dont un tiers avec avec
des enfants et qui donc reste chez elle
parce qu'il n'y a pas de place
d'hébergement il y a combien de
féminicides qu'on calcule moi après moi
le retard de la France est probant il
faut faire comme l'Espagne il faut
vraiment avoir un plan une priorité
nationale ça se traduit dans les
priorités budgétaires et c'est pas avec
un pas je vais pas dire de sénateur mais
1000 places par an ben non il faut plus
nous avons du retard donc il faut
démultiplier il faut que ces quatre
femmes aient une place et et notamment
celles qui sont avec enfants encore plus
donc non je n'entends pas votre argument
vous progressez mais pas assez vite
merci alors je mets aux voix donc
l'amendement 391 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le
1053 car je suis même à vie qui est pour
contre
l'amendement 93 madame artiguez
merci madame la Présidente sept
amendement monsieur le ministre visa
augmenter de 95 millions d'euros les
crédits de paiement de l'action 4
rénovation urbaines et amélioration du
cadre de vie du programme 147 politique
de la ville en effet l'État s'est engagé
à contribué à hauteur de 10% du
Programme national de renouvellement
urbain le NPN ru soit 1,2 milliards
d'euros sur 12 milliards d'euros au
total au cours du président quinquennat
il avait promis de verser 200 millions
d'euros seul
92,6 millions d'euros ont été
effectivement payés à la rue le solde
est d'environ 1,1 milliard d'euros sur
les 10 prochaines années soit un rythme
de décaissement moyen de 110 millions
d'euros par an dans le PLF pour 2023
seul 15 millions d'euros sont inscrits
le présent amendement vise donc à porter
les autorisations d'engagement les
critiques de paiement de paiement à 110
millions d'euros lors de mes auditions
il m'a été indiquée qu'un arbitrage
aurait été rendu pour 40 pour garantir
300 millions d'euros sur les prochaines
années mais vous laisserez l'essentiel
de la charge pour la période finale soit
plus de 800 millions d'euros de 2028 à
2031 je rappelle que ce qui n'est pas
mis dans les caisses maintenant dans les
budgets devra être mis plus tard donc
cette augmentation est formellement
gagée sur l'action 4 du programme 135
pour assurer la recevabilité de la
demande de banque
merci la vie de la Commission sur un
porteur
madame la Présidente je comprends fort
bien l'intention de cette amendement
j'en profite pour saluer la force
l'engagement notre collègue et Madame
Martigues sur ces sujets
de quoi s'agit-il on a un PNRU qui doit
être pourvu de 12 milliards d'euros dont
8 milliards apportés par action au
logement 2,8 milliards par les bailleurs
sociaux 1,2 milliards par l'État qui
sont logement et les réseaux sociaux
apportent leur contribution chaque année
et ce n'est pas le cas de l'État jusqu'à
présent puisque les crédits chaque année
sur le programme 147 sont symboliques
très symbolique de l'ordre de 15
millions d'euros chaque année
d'où le fait que je comprenne bien
l'intention de de cet amendement de
mettre en cohérence les actions avec les
annonces pour autant l'enrue ne fait pas
état pour l'instant de difficulté de
paiement il s'agirait pas pour nous de
cautionner un abonnement de trésorerie
et une ouverture de crédit ne serait
donc en état de cause nécessaire que si
la contribution des autres partenaires
diminués en conséquence j'ai pas cette
information
à ce stade de l'histoire la difficulté
n'est pas à court terme elle réside dans
la stratégie de financement un moyen
terme du npru avec ce sujet d'Action
Logement qui nous qui nous préoccupe
toutes et tous voir qui nous révolte
parfois puisque Action Logement est
soumis à une pression sans précédent de
la part de l'État et l'État qui devra en
tirer évidemment les conséquences de
tout cela les conséquences ses propres
décisions je rappelle que le Sénat s'est
opposé au principe de ce prélèvement de
300 millions de de d'action d'Action
Logement prévues par l'article 16 que
c'est un acte fort
et j'y vois un appel au gouvernement
pour qu'il indique enfin quelle priorité
il entend tracer en termes de politique
de logement de l'urbanisme tout
particulièrement
en matière de renouvellement
urbain donc ce sera en l'état une
proposition de retrait de cet abonnement
après bien sûr avoir entendu le monsieur
le ministre sur ces éléments la vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci
madame la Présidente c'est le rapporteur
madame la sénatrice ça a été rappelé et
vous connaissez mon attachement et mon
attention sur le programme de
renouvellement urbain et et sur cette
très belle agence qu'elle en rue lors du
quinquennat précédent le le budget de la
rue alloué est passé de 5 10 puis 12
milliards d'euros ce qui veut dire que
dans les années qui viennent c'est
environ 48 milliards d'euros qui seront
dépensés en faveur des quartiers
populaires et c'est extrêmement
important c'est une dynamique rarement
atteinte et qui continuera à changer la
vie dans dans ces quartiers sur ces 12
milliards d'euros oui effectivement
l'engagement de l'État c'est 1,2
milliards d'euros mais je peux vous
assurer que la trésorerie actuelle de la
rue qui est de plus de 1000 millions ne
nécessite pas à ce stade un effort
supplémentaire de l'État mais comme vous
l'avez dit
l'engagement du gouvernement sur ce
quinquennat de 300 millions d'euros sera
tenu à bondé en fonction des besoins et
du travail que l'on mènera avec leur rue
tout au long des échanges moi d'une
certaine manière vous savez plus les
collectivités font plus la rue a besoin
de décaisser mieux c'est donc je n'ai
aucun doute sur la volonté des uns et
des autres de faire j'étais à Marseille
pendant deux jours pour regarder
l'avancée des programmes en rue je le
faisais comme président de la rue et je
continuerai à le faire comme ministre
l'important pour les quartiers
populaires c'est que ces projets se
réalisent et plus on demandera à la rue
de décaisser mieux ça sera merci merci
merci madame la Présidente moi je
soutiendrai évidemment l'amendement
présenté par notre golem que Viviane
artiguelas puisque c'est un amendement
de notre commission je suis sûr que je
ferai plaisir à Monsieur le Ministre
j'en suis certaine pour connaître votre
engagement sur le NPN rue je suis sûr
que je ferai plaisir à Monsieur le
Ministre qui aujourd'hui a d'autres
obligations et d'autres contraintes mais
je vous prends au mot monsieur le
ministre plus on des caissera vite plus
on sera content plus nos concitoyens
seront contents donc véritablement le
signal que la Commission veut envoyer là
c'est un signal d'accélération de ces
opérations de de réaménagement et de
rénovation urbaine il faut qu'on donne
au territoire la possibilité d'aller
plus vite et il faut qu'on donne ce
signe de l'engagement de l'État c'est
tout l'objet de cet amendement qui est
un abonnement pour nous extrêmement
symbolique de la volonté de l'État
d'aller plus vite sur la rénovation
urbaine je voterai donc cet amendement
oui je suis d'accord avec vous monsieur
le rapporteur sur le fait
qu'effectivement la rue n'a pas besoin
de trésorerie ce que en accord avec la
présidente d'admission des affaires
économiques je voudrais vraiment alerter
sur le fait que
cet argent il va en avoir besoin très
rapidement et ce qu'on ne met pas
aujourd'hui en crédit de paiement on
n'est pas certain malgré l'engagement de
monsieur le ministre qui y sera plus
tard je crois que c'est un signe
important à donner moi j'ai quelques
doutes parfois sur la possibilité vos
marges de manœuvre par rapport à Bercy
monsieur le ministre donc vraiment je
crois qu'il est important que cet
amendement soit voté très symboliquement
pour bien montrer que l'État s'engage
s'engage dans cette voie sur des longues
années que demande le essai financements
qui vont être absolument nécessaires
pour le NPN RU et vous vous y êtes
engagé les taxis engagés il faut qu'il
respecte ses engagements
merci alors je mets aux voix donc la
maman 93 qui a reçu un avis défavorable
de la commission et du gouvernement qui
est pour
qui contre qui s'abstient il est donc
adopté alors trois amendements
identiques le 362 monsieur Belin
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur alors
les 6 amendements qui suit
sont la même sujet font suite à deux
rapports sénatoriaux sur l'état des
ponts en France qui faisait eux-mêmes
suite monsieur le ministre au dramatique
accident du pont de gêne en août 2018
alors le sujet est aussi grave monsieur
le ministre parce que d'abord on a un
problème de recensement et
d'identification des ponts en France qui
est propriétaire de quoi vous avez près
de 10% des ponts et ouvrages jars qui
sont orphelins et donc et pour ça qu'il
y a mon nez des amendements pour avoir
des crédits de paiement pour se faire ce
travail de recensement parce que un
moment donné on doit savoir quel
collectivité peut potentiellement être
en responsabilité
vous savez l'état des ponts a beaucoup
changé la plupart ont été fait avant le
20e siècle c'est un au lendemain de la
guerre c'était pas les mêmes sujets de
circulation c'était pas les mêmes sujets
de trafic les tonnages n'étaient pas les
mêmes depuis on a fait aussi le constat
que évidemment les épaisses les épisodes
de sécheresse et de
changement climatiques sont venus
affaiblir nos ouvrages d'art et
affaiblir les ponts et donc on a besoin
de travaux en urgence en urgence parce
que on voit bien que skate est fait
après le plan de relance ne suffit pas
c'est pour ça qu'on vous demande dans
les amendements que l'on a voulu soit au
niveau de la Commission soit avec notre
collection pour effectivement avoir ces
crédits de paiement parce que des
travaux doivent être fait
et puis alors me dites pas monsieur le
ministre que je sais gagé parce que en
plus là c'est une question de sécurité
je vous rappelle quand même que c'est
200 à 250 000 ponts et ouvrages d'art
concernés en France qu'on nous parle de
10% sans savoir qui est propriétaire que
bien souvent on se retrouve aussi avec
des ouvrages d'art et des ponts en
milieu rural c'est le cas de tous les
anciens ponts des anciennes lignes de
chemin de fer on est donc face à des
collectivités de petite taille ou des
collectivités rurales qui n'ont pas les
moyens ni d'ingénierie ni les moyens
financiers d'engager ces pompes de ces
travaux et donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
besoin en assistance de maîtrise
d'ouvrage du CRMA et évidemment besoin
de crédit de paiement c'est l'objet des
six amendements madame la Présidente qui
suivent et qui sont présentés devant
vous
merci donc vous avez présenté 388
également monsieur chevrolier vous avez
le 498 oui merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
ou c'est un amendement identique mais
qui qui vise effectivement à créer un
programme dédié au sein de la mission
cohésion des territoires abondés de 60
millions pour pour soutenir les
collectivités
locales dans l'entretien les réparations
des ponts il y a le programme national
pompe piloté par par le cerema qui
prévoit des cofinancement et donc on a
un besoin de soutien de l'État et on a
une nécessité de sécurité ces ouvrages
on a on le doit on doit cette sécurité à
nos concitoyens quel est le sens de cet
amendement merci David la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
madame la président de Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues donc comme ça a
été rappelé cet amendement prévoit de
créer un fond pour l'entretien et la
réparations aux ouvrages d'art et
notamment au pont qui représente une
charge importante notamment dans les
plus petites communes vous l'avez
rappelé alors je souscris bien entendu à
cette idée qui est une bonne idée c'est
un sujet important alors le problème
c'est que cette ce sujet là ne relève
pas de la mission cohésion des
territoires puisque pour les ouvrages
d'art
on est sur la mission écologique et
transport sur le programme 203 et j'en
profite pour rappeler que dans la loi de
finance rectificative qu'on a voté il y
a quelques jours en décembre on a voté
un amendement en prévoyant d'abander à
60 millions d'euros ce programme sur les
ouvrages d'art qui a d'ailleurs été
retenu au final dans la commission mixte
paritaire et qui donc au final est et
aujourd'hui actif et pour être une ces
crédit là pour être utile utilisé bien
entendu en 2023 et d'ailleurs on avait
précisément les communes parce que c'est
bien à l'échelle des communes et des
plus petites que ce poste principalement
cette difficulté à l'entretien et la
restauration des ouvrages d'art donc
c'est une demande de retrait merci la
vie du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur comme ça déjà été dit l'état
soutien fortement les communes
propriétaires d'ouvrage d'art et de pont
grâce aux 40 millions d'euros l'étude
pilotée par le serrera a déjà permis de
l'expertise de plus de 40
000 ponts et comme ça vient d'être très
bien dit par le rapporteur c'est pas la
peine que je le redise c'est une
enveloppe de 50 millions d'euros qui a
été prévue dans le programme 203 et donc
je partage la proposition de retrait
merci
alors je monsieur Jeunet
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre je voudrais à mon tour saluer
le travail qui a été conduit sur ces
bancs depuis plusieurs années maintenant
que ce soit par nos collègues Moret
chaise et Dagbert en 2019 ou plus
récemment l'excellent rapport conduit
par Bruno Belin qui est sur tous les
bureaux des maires de commune rurales et
qui s'en inspirent très largement je
voudrais également en profiter pour
saluer le travail du serema qui
accompagne les collectivités céréma qui
est présidé par une saône-et-loirienne
Marie-Claude Jaro je voudrais insister
pour ma part monsieur le ministre parce
que mercredi nous avions une discussion
avec votre collègue sur la prise en
compte de la voirie communale dans le
calcul de la DSR et on nous a expliqué
que finalement on pouvait finalement se
passer de ce critère là et je me dis que
finalement il y a une certaine
continuité dans les réponses des
différents ministres puisque après ne
pas avoir pris en compte les routes
communales maintenant finalement ce sont
les ponts qu'on sur lesquels on voudrait
fermer les yeux moi je voudrais insister
sur le fait qu'effectivement c'est un
vrai sujet de sécurité c'est un vrai
sujet d'attractivité et d'égalité
d'accès de nos concitoyens à un certain
nombre de services que ce soit pour les
activités y compris agricoles qui se
déroulent dans nos territoires ruraux
que ce soit également pour les
infirmières les médecins qui se
déplacent à domicile nous avons besoin
vraiment de mettre le paquet sur ce
sujet et effectivement pour compléter ce
qui a été dit sur le défaut d'ingénierie
souvent ce que l'on vit sur le
territoire c'est que même lorsque c'est
l'intercommunalité qui reprend la
compétence et bien lorsqu'ensuite on
recherche des cofinancement c'est très
difficile parce que si vous prenez tous
les ponts communaux en compétence à
tarcommunale lorsque vous venez ensuite
en commission de doter le préfet vous
demande de choisir un ou deux projets
par communauté de communes et donc vous
n'avez pas de subvention sans parler des
départements et des régions ou des fonds
européens qui sont parfois peu attentifs
à ces sujets donc on a vraiment besoin
d'une mobilisation nationale sur le
sujet merci Monsieur Belin
merci Madame présente une chemise faut
vraiment être sérieux vu la gravité du
sujet alors j'ai entendu le rapporteur
qui parle de 60 millions vous même de 50
millions
c'est près de 3 milliards d'euros qui
sont aujourd'hui nécessaires dont 150
millions en urgence donc je crois à
Monsieur Miss on peut pas passer sur ce
sujet là qui touche tous les territoires
qui va mettre les élus locaux et
notamment les élus ruraux dans une vraie
difficulté parce que plus le temps passe
plus les choses se dégradent donc là ce
qu'on vous dit qu'il y a une urgence à
être mobilisée c'est que nous le vivons
comme ça a été rappelé par notre
collègue Fabien Genest cette réalité sur
le terrain ça nous est remonté par les
collectivités par les agences
départementales qui aujourd'hui
accompagnent les élus donc là maintenant
il faut qu'on passe
vraiment à la décision faut qu'on rentre
dans l'action le pont de gêne il est
dans toutes les têtes ça peut arriver en
France prochainement et on pourra pas
dire qu'on ne savait pas donc
l'amendement sera maintenu madame la
Présidente merci oui monsieur le
rapporteur
oui juste pour préciser que la demande
de retrait de la commission n'est pas
attachée à un désintérêt pour ce sujet
là et je mesure ça de très près dans mon
département simplement les crédits pour
les réparations entretien des ouvrages
d'art relève du programme 203 de la
mission écologie et transport et non pas
de la mission du programme 112 et de la
mission cohésion des territoires c'est
ce qui justifie la demande de retraite
merci monsieur le rapporteur alors je
vais mettre aux voix donc ces trois
amendements identiques 360 de 388 498
qui ont reçu un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient sont adoptés
troisième amendements identiques le 361
monsieur Belin vous les avez défendus
d'accord donc 361 386 défendus monsieur
Chevrollier pour le
497 défendu la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur défavorable merci
la vie du gouvernement
merci je mets aux voix donc ces trois
amendements identiques 361 386 497 avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient sont adoptés
alors deux amendements
identiques le 374 madame Estrosi Sassone
la présidente monsieur le ministrement
vise à rétablir l'APL accession appelle
accession qui a été supprimée par la loi
de finances de 2018 sur les logements
neufs qui avaient été néanmoins maintenu
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2019 sur les
logements anciens dans les zones
détendues puis qui en 2019 a été de
nouveau mis en application mais
uniquement pour notre mère illustrer
ainsi la politique du stop and go qui a
été la politique du logement tout au
long de la précédente mandature cet
amendement appel accession c'est un
amendement que nous portons ici sur tous
les bancs du Sénat depuis sa suppression
en 2018 parce que nous considérons qu'il
s'agit là d'un outil qui est essentiel
pour faire redémarrer le parcours
résidentiel vous avez dit vous même dans
votre propos que vous étiez
particulièrement attaché et que le
parcours résidentiel était l'une de vos
priorités et bien commençons par
rétablir l'APL accession parce que nous
le savons tous aujourd'hui bon nombre de
ménages et plus particulièrement de
ménage dans les zones qui sont
extrêmement tendues ne peuvent pas
réaliser leurs projets de d'accession à
la propriété d'autant plus actuellement
avec la hausse des taux d'intérêts et
c'est important aussi parce que ça
permet de fluidifier le parcours
résidentiel ça permet de augmenter le
taux de rotation dans le parc HLM et
donc autant de facteurs qui sont de
nature par rapport à la crise du
logement que nous connaissons mais
surtout par rapport à l'aspiration d'un
grand nombre de nos concitoyens de
pouvoir soit acheter un logement soit le
construire à travers l'appel accession
par également des outils comme le bail
réel solidaire ou comme le PSLA donc je
vous demande véritablement d'entendre ce
que nous faisons ici et ce que nous
demandons chaque année au Sénat de
rétablir cet appel d'accession ces 50
millions d'euros monsieur le ministre
des économies budgétaires c'est pas par
là que ça commence et je vous ça
permettrait à plus de 300 000 ménages
aujourd'hui de pouvoir formaliser leurs
projets d'accession à la propriété merci
Madame linman pour le 1085
identique
mais amendement que celle de notre
collègue extrusifessonne juste un
argument de plus dans le cadre du
parcours résidentiel on voit des
familles qui voudraient accéder à la
propriété qui ne peuvent pas parce qu'il
y a un problème de solvabilité notamment
parce qu'il y a plus l'appel accession
qui vont toucher l'APL locative dans un
logement alors qu'elle pourrait le
libérer et par ailleurs on ferait
koudouble favoriser l'accession sociale
libérer du logement locatif donc cet
accession n'est pas ruineuse pour l'État
serait un vrai levier au passage
monsieur le ministre notre Sénat voté la
prolongation du PTZ au-delà de
l'échéance de fin 2023 c'est très
important pour éviter le stopango de
Stoven Go dans le l'accession sociale
quelle sera l'attitude du gouvernement
par rapport à ce vote
merci la vie de la commission sur le
rapporteur
merci beaucoup la vidéo gouvernement
monsieur le ministre même avis monsieur
le ministre
madame
la sénatrice mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs vous proposez effectivement de
rétablir l'appel accession à la
propriété
cette extension a été prévue depuis 2018
il a en revanche était maintenu en
outre-mer comme vous l'avez rappelé le
gouvernement a privilégié quant à lui
d'autres dispositifs que vous connaissez
que vous avez cité le PSLA le PTZ sur
lequel nous souhaitons continuer à
travailler le prêt accession sociale et
bien sûr le PRS et vous le savez j'en ai
pas parlé dans mon discours général mais
le Conseil national de la refondation
que nous avons lancé en début de semaine
doit être le lieu du travail et de la
réflexion la réflexion la plus large
possible sans aucun a priori et sans
aucun interdit et ce que je vous propose
c'est de laisser le temps de la
réflexion le temps de la réflexion au
parcours résidentiel et à la capacité de
répondre
aux différentes difficultés des Français
permet d'accéder au logement à la
propriété et à la location et donc en
attendant le temps de cette réflexion ce
serait un avis défavorable merci
Monsieur Gremillet
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre monsieur le rapporteur cher
collègue moi je pense que c'est
amendement il est absolument capital
on le sait tous et je remercie le
rapporteur de son très très favorable
parce qu'on a fait il y a pas si
longtemps ici un travail considérable
pour permettre à plus de familles
d'accéder effectivement la propriété je
pense à l'assurance emprunteur alors
d'un côté on fait des efforts et je
comprends pas la position de monsieur le
ministre qui est de dire on va attendre
on va regarder non il y a une nécessité
absolue et je soutiens complètement cet
amendement je trouve qu'il est vraiment
pertinent et il donne vraiment un signal
à temps de famille qui ont un besoin
effectivement de pouvoir accéder à cette
propriété sur le G merci même ma
président prima
merci madame la Présidente naturellement
je vais soutenir cet amendement et je
remercie le rapporteur également de de
son avis monsieur le ministre laissé du
temps pour la réflexion mais vous avez
dans ce Sénat des personnes qui sont et
vous le savez des grandes spécialistes
du logement je parle de Dominique bien
sûr je parle de Marie-Noëlle je parle de
Valérie létharge parle de Viviane
Artigalas qui se projet après projet qui
rapporte après rapport montre l'intérêt
et vous-même d'ailleurs de votre
discours vous l'avez dit le parcours
résidentiel est un élément structurant
de la politique du logement cet
amendement il coûte rien il coûte 50
millions d'euros à l'État rien du tout
et c'est un élément déclencheur du
parcours résidentiel c'est un aimant qui
va libérer du logement social et qui va
donner un coup de pouce récurrent sur le
monde du logement et et sur la
construction par pitié monsieur le
ministre
accepter je veux dire moi je pense à
Philippe d'allier qui a longtemps qui a
longtemps également défendu ce
amendement soyez le premier ministre à
voilà à lutter un peu contre la partie
sud de Bercy et s'il vous plaît
restaurer de la cohérence restaurer de
la cohérence dans le parcours
résidentiel on votera bien sûr cet
amendement merci même la présidente
l'état très rapidement pour dire tout
simplement monsieur le ministre que s'il
y a bien un sujet sur lequel on a plus
besoin de se faire une idée sur la
question c'est bien celui d'un
dispositif qui depuis très longtemps est
identifié dans le paysage comme
essentiel à la poursuite d'un parcours
résidentiel et n'ayant fait en sorte
qu'ils ne manque aucun maillon à la
chaîne alors comme ça a été dit
brillamment partout mes collègues
évidemment on va soutenir cet amendement
et monsieur le ministre a bien encore
une fois quelque chose qui ne souffre
d'aucun doute sur son efficience et ça
nécessitait c'est bien cet outil de la
paix alors vous l'avez entendu monsieur
le ministre pourquoi être en opposition
à quelque chose qui est juste la voix du
bon sens et du terrain merci Madame
Estrosi Sassone
très brièvement moi je voulais vous avez
fait référence monsieur le ministre
conseille national de la refondation je
pense qu'il y a des sujets beaucoup plus
importants qui feront l'objet des
travaux du Conseil national de la
refondation je pense en particulier et
prenez le nouveau mot sur le statut du
bailleur privé là il y a effectivement
des raisons de pouvoir tous ensemble
réfléchir et aboutir sur ce que nous
réclamons ici au Sénat depuis aussi un
certain nombre d'années et donc sur
d'autres sujets mais pas sur celui de la
paix d'accession ne nous dites pas
encore comme bon nombre de vos collègues
on va faire un groupe de travail on va
réfléchir on fera des propositions non
tout de suite rétablissons cet outil
cette aide qui est indispensable pour
faire en sorte que le parcours
résidentiel qui est aujourd'hui bloqué
voir complètement bloqué dans les
territoires qui en ont le plus besoin et
bien puissent enfin redémarrer
merci alors je vais mettre aux voix donc
ces deux amendements identiques 374 et
1045 qui ont reçu un avis favorable de
la commission défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient ils sont adoptés
alors l'amendement 1060 même filleule
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre c'est un amendement donc de
monsieur taudéchini qui concerne les
maisons France service en effet le
forfait pris en charge par l'État et les
opérateurs
30000 euros par an en moyenne pour ces
maisons francs services et loin de
couvrir les dépenses engagées par les
collectivités en effet le rapport du
Sénat de juillet 2022 évalue leur coût
moyen à 110 000 euros par an et l'État
s'était engagé à participer à hauteur de
50% du coût annuel d'une maison France
service dans le cadre du PLFR 2022 le
Sénat a voté un amendement porté par
notre collègue Bernard delcro qui
prévoit une hausse de 12,5 millions
d'euros soit 5000 euros supplémentaires
par maison pour 2022 c'est une première
étape mais on reste loin du compte
compte tenu de la situation financière
des collectivités qui portent fois
plusieurs maisons France services car
majoritairement situé dans des zones
rurales peu denses notre amendement
propose d'augmenter la participation de
l'État de 50 millions d'euros
supplémentaires pour 2023 cette
augmentation permettra de passer la
prise en charge par l'État et ses
opérateurs de 30 000 à 50000 euros par
maison le déploiement des maisons France
service connaît une montée en charge
tant quantitative que qualitative il est
important que l'État ils prennent toute
sa part je vous remercie
la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
chers collègues
madame figgle cette amendement concerne
les maisons francs services vous savez
que c'est un sujet qui me qui me tient à
cœur et vous avez fait référence je je
vous en remercie il propose donc
d'aborder les crédits en service à
hauteur de 50 millions d'euros pour
porter 50000 euros par maison la
participation finalement le soutien aux
collectivités ou aux autres opérateurs
parce qu'il y a aussi d'autres
opérateurs qui portent des maisons
France service alors je veux juste je
partage évidemment l'objectif et j'ai
proposé ces 50.000 euros dans le rapport
que j'avais présenté en commission des
finances vous l'avez rappelé je veux
simplement rappeler quelque chose
aujourd'hui la contribution le soutien
qui est apporté au porteur des maisons
France service et notamment aux
collectivité qui portent environ les
deux tiers des maisons France service
c'est 30000 euros mais sur ces 30000
euros c'est 15000 euros pour l'État et
15000 euros pour les opérateurs ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui pour apporter ces
15000 euros au titre du FNA DT sur
programme 112 l'état consacre à peu près
37 millions d'euros
je partage l'objectif de porter à 50000
euros c'est la proposition que j'avais
faite mais c'est 50 000 euros je propose
qu'il soit pris en charge à parité entre
l'État et les opérateurs comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui ce qui supposerait que
l'État pour atteindre ce0.000 euros par
maison qui est tout à fait justifié ça
supposerait que l'État apporte 10000
euros supplémentaires par rapport à ce
qui est apporté aujourd'hui c'est à dire
environ 25 millions d'euros dans le vous
l'avez rappelé dans le la loi de finance
rectificative on a franchi un premier
pas en apportant 5000 euros
supplémentaires donc 12 millions et demi
12,5 millions d'euros donc ce qu'il
manque aujourd'hui c'est pour rappeler
un peu le les chiffres ce qu'il manque
aujourd'hui en participation de l'État
pour atteindre les 50000 euros si on
reste sur un système à parité avec les
opérateurs ce serait 12,5 millions
d'euros supplémentaires
je je propose que comment vous dire ça
je propose un retrait silence sera un
avis défavorable pour les chiffres que
je viens de rappeler mais aussi je veux
rappeler en 2023
il y aura le renouvellement de la
convention avec les opérateurs et je
pense qu'il est extrêmement important
qu'on convienne que dans la
participation à 50 000 euros que l'on
prévoit même objectif que les opérateurs
continuent à financer à parité donc on a
fait un premier pas dans le PLF je
propose que en attente la renégociation
de la convention de 2023 avec les
opérateurs pour essayer de les amener
sur cet objectif à 50.000 euros ce qui
nécessiterait pour l'État seulement 5000
euros de plus leur maison c'est-à-dire
12,5 millions d'euros ces raisons pour
laquelle je propose un retrait ou à
défaut ça sera un avis défavorable merci
la vie du gouvernement monsieur ministre
merci madame la Présidente exactement
pour le même même raison que que
monsieur le rapporteur entre les 5000
euros déjà ajouté et la négociation qui
doit avoir lieu très vite pour que
chacun prenne sa part et notamment les
opérateurs dans les maisons de France
service je propose un retrait sinon ça
sera un avis défavorable merci donc je
mets au voile à un moment 1060 car je
suis en avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui ça tient n'est pas
adoptée 989 monsieur gilet
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre dans la pleine lignée des
travaux de la mission flash sur les
mesures d'accompagnement à la mise en
oeuvre des et des feux les eaux d'un
faible émission Messieurs les Députés
Gérard le seul et Monsieur Bruno
milleniène nous ont proposé la création
de postes de conseiller mobilité dans
les maisons France service donc nous
reprenons effectivement cette
proposition ce conseiller aurait pour
mission d'apporter conseil à chacune et
chacun des habitants en ressentant le
besoin sur les solutions alternatives de
mobilité existantes afin de les rendre
connues de tous et toutes et surtout de
les optimiser c'est un moment un pour
but de financer donc des ressources
humaines l'article 40 et l'article 47 de
l'organique loi de finances interdisant
parlementaire d'augmenter les crédits la
mesure est gagée sur les crédits de
programmes d'urbanistes territoire et
amélioration d'habitat l'objectif est
bien sûr que le gouvernement puisse
lever ce gage cette mesure allant dans
le bon sens pour améliorer la mobilité
du quotidien
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
madame la présente alors sur le
l'objectif que pour les habitants qui
sont concernés par les zones ZFE et
puisse y avoir une information un
accompagnement un guichet en quelque
sorte on est tout à fait d'accord en
revanche il me semble que adosser ses
conseillers aux maisons France services
n'est sans doute pas le bon ciblage
parce que vous avez beaucoup de mes
enfants services notamment en territoire
ruraux sur lequel il y a pas du tout ZF
alors aujourd'hui il y a déjà d'ailleurs
des communes qui ont mis un guichet pour
informer les habitants sur les adefe
mais mais très franchement créer des
postes adossés mais en France services
je pensais pas le bon ciblage parce que
la très grande majorité des maisons
France services sont en dehors et même
très éloignés des zones ZF donc pour
cette raison là c'est une demande de
retrait merci la vie du gouvernement
monsieur ministre
même avis que monsieur le rapporteur
merci
très rapidement la proposition est bien
détendre un conseil mobilité à
l'ensemble des territoires pas
exclusivement aux et des feux
merci alors je mets au voile amendement
989 carrossier un avis défavorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre
qui s'appity ce n'est pas adoptée
1048 président requier
[Musique]
qui propose de consacrer 28 millions
d'euros au recrutement 816 projets
environ 35000 euros par ATP afin
d'accompagner le lancement d'un nouveau
programme vierge à venir qui permettrait
d'adapter le programme Action coeur de
ville et petite ville de demain au
village ruraux et hyperero c'est chef de
projet sera ainsi mis à disposition des
communes et des communautés de communes
rurales et hyper rurales
alors j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure dans
mon intervention que j'ai été favorable
à un programme village d'avenir qu'il
faudra qu'il faudra accompagner
simplement là l'amendement propose de
créer 800 chefs de projet pour
accompagner les communes dans le cadre
de ces de ce programme village
d'Asnières qui n'est pas encore mis en
place donc ça me semble un peu prématuré
on a déjà aujourd'hui d'ailleurs je
pense qu'il faudra d'ailleurs un peu
mettre à plat l'ensemble des dispositifs
d'aide en ingénierie interne aux
collectivités parce que on a les chefs
de projet des petites villes de demain
on a les volontaires territoriaux en
administration on a les chefs de projets
cœur de ville on a aussi une aide sur
fabrique de territoires on a des chefs
de projet ou des chargés de mission sur
territoire d'industrie on a les
conseillers numériques alors
généralement c'est à l'échelle
intercommunale ça pose le problème de
l'accompagnement de l'échelon communale
je pense que de mon point de vue il faut
d'abord qu'on remettre un peu de l'ordre
qu'on remette à plat en tous les cas
l'ensemble ce dispositif pour essayer de
n'ont pas de réduire mais en tout cas de
rendre plus efficace et d'optimiser
cette accompagnement des collectivités
et pour ce qui est de l'échelon
communale je pense vraiment que ce sujet
mérite d'être abordé dans le cadre d'un
programme village d'avenir qui j'espère
verra le jour dans le cadre de l'agenda
rural deuxième 2e génération mais
recruter 800 chefs de projet pour aider
800 communes finalement parce que
l'ingénierie existe au niveau
intercommunal mais pas toujours au
niveau communal ça a été rappelé créer
800 chefs de projets pour aider des
communes on va cibler quelques communes
on va laisser beaucoup de côtés donc je
vous propose de reprendre ce sujet au
moment de l'examen d'un programme
village d'asir donc c'est une demande de
retraite merci la vie du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre
même la présidente monsieur le sénateur
vous le savez l'anct et et sera très en
soutien comme elle l'a toujours été
depuis sa création en destination des
territoires et des collectivités les
plus rurales ma collègue Dominique Faure
a annoncé le travail en permanence sur
l'agenda rurale et donc en attendant que
tous ces travaux aboutissent je suis
d'accord avec le rapporteur pour
proposer un retrait j'ai retiré merci
alors le 1061 madame filleul oui madame
la Présidente Monsieur le Ministre la
question a été largement développée dans
les interventions liminaires le nombre
de communes soutenues en ingénierie par
la NCT hors dispositif action cœur de
ville ou petite ville de demain reste
encore trop faible au regard des 25 000
communes de moins de 1000 habitants pour
lesquels les moyens d'ingénierie sont
souvent très limités voire inexistants
le Sénat a lancé une mission pour
évaluer la réelle plus-value de la NCT
pour les collectivités territoriales
nous verrons les mesures d'ajustement
nécessaires mais dans cette attente il y
a néanmoins
urgence pour les territoires à se
préparer au chantier structurant que
sont la transition écologique la mise en
oeuvre d'usane ou encore l'accueil de
nouvelles populations et de nouvelles
activités d'autant que le contexte n'est
pas favorable à la crise énergétique qui
s'inscrit dans la durée le retour de
l'inflation s'ajoute l'incertitude sur
les ressources des collectivités la mise
en place du fond vert pourrait pallier
ce manque de moyens mais son objectif
exact ne paraît pas encore bien arrêté
ces modalités de gestion pouvant encore
être clarifié c'est la raison pour
laquelle notre amendement propose
d'amplifier l'action de la NCT dans son
rôle d'appui dédié aux projets
territoriaux des petites communes avec
une ingénierie sur mesure des moyens
suffisants c'est en effet la garantie
qu'il y aura une équité territoriale en
faveur des territoires les plus fragiles
c'est la garantie d'être en mesure de
concrétiser les grandes transitions dans
les territoires ruraux c'est enfin
redonné confiance aux élus pour les
développements de leur projet de
territoire notre amendement propose
d'augmenter les crédits dédiés à
l'ingénierie des petits des projets des
petites communes à hauteur de 20
millions d'euros
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
[Musique]
la continuité de ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure je connais vraiment parfaitement
la question des difficultés de communes
je suis mais rester mère très longtemps
d'un petit village de 400 habitants des
difficultés des communes avec des
secrétariats de mairie parfois à temps
partiel pour arriver à faire face à
toutes les tâches et notamment et
notamment à monter les projets et à les
suivre donc je mesure ça parfaitement et
c'est vrai vous le dites d'ailleurs il y
a 25000 communes vous l'avez évalué à
25000 25000 communes petites communes de
moins de 1000 habitants qui finalement
se trouve en dehors des programmes
existants petite ville de demain un cœur
de ville et autres donc il y a un sujet
sur l'accompagnement des petites
communes en même temps on peut pas
mettre un chef de projet dans les 25000
petites communes donc c'est un sujet je
le connais vraiment parfaitement pour
l'avoir vécu en tant que mère d'un petit
village je pense que encore une fois et
c'est pas pour renvoyer à plus tard la
question mais par question de cohérence
au moment où on est quand même nombreux
à être d'accord pour défendre l'idée
d'un programme village d'avenir ça veut
pas dire qu'il y aura un chef un projet
dans toutes les communes mais en tous
les cas au moment où on est d'accord et
où on essaie de de convaincre en quelque
sorte Dominique fort la ministre en
charge de la ruralité de mettre en place
ce programme village d'avenir c'est
c'est vraiment à ce moment-là qu'il va
falloir qu'on regarde comment on peut
arriver à aider ces petites communes qui
ont vraiment même pas d'ingénierie très
peu de service et qui en même temps ont
besoin de monter des projets très
accompagnés dans un cadre qui est de
plus en plus compliqué sur le plan
administratif technique et autres on
pourrait citer des cas et j'en connais
par cœur donc je vous propose vraiment
de de regarder à ce moment là comment on
peut mais vraiment de manière concrète
pas seulement avec des sommes mais comme
de manière très concrète sur le terrain
aider ces petites communes qui en effet
se trouvent exclus des dispositifs des
programmes qui sont en cours
merci la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
mais ma vie que monsieur le rapporteur
qu'il a très bien exprimé
alors je vais mettre
pardon retrait ah oui mais en général je
demande pas comme ça parce que sinon on
prend la parole donc je mets au voir
l'amendement 1061 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable à la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté mon 1049 président
16 millions d'euros à transformation des
contrats de volontariat territoriale
administration en contrat de chaises
afin d'accompagner les besoins en
ingénierie du territoire ruraux
ce recrutement périr des postes sables
stables et puis expérimentés de chaînes
de projets devraient attirer plus de
candidats
merci David la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
alors dans la précédente donc on est
toujours sur la question de du soutien à
l'ingénierie des territoires je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure il y a eu beaucoup de
mesures qui se sont déployées je dois le
dire parfois de façon un peu rapide et
dispersée sans forcément être être
soutenu par une une démarche cohérente
avec encore une fois des chargés de
projets cœur de ville chargé de projet
petite ville de demain chargé de mission
les volontaires territoriaux en
administration et beaucoup d'autres
d'ailleurs sur il était prévu d'ouvrir
800 postes de volontaires territoriale
administration il y en a que 200
finalement qui ont été qui ont été
demandés et pourvus donc je pense que
avant de transformer ces VTA en emploi
pérenne je pense qu'il faut vraiment et
ça rejoint les discussions précédentes
mettre à plat tous ces dispositifs de
soutien à l'ingénierie dans les
territoires pour essayer d'avoir un
ensemble et un système qui soit cohérent
et efficace parce que pour être
efficacement il faut que ce soit
cohérent complémentaire donc donc c'est
pour ça que c'est une demande de retrait
merci David du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
monsieur
le sénateur vous avez raison le
programme VTR est un programme de grande
qualité mais néanmoins je ne crois pas
que
transformer les postes soit d'actualité
et au contraire peut-être auraient un
effet négatif sur le programme tel qu'il
existe aujourd'hui et donc à ce stade je
vous propose comme sur rapporteur un
retrait sinon ça sera un avis
défavorable merci monsieur le Président
qui connaît bien le point des communes
rural et du gouvernement dont je retire
la main de vol
le mix le 1059 monsieur montaugée merci
madame la Présidente de Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues on le mesure
depuis en plus le zanne et de loin le
dispositif qui va impacter le plus
fortement nos territoires dans les
décennies à venir c'est un enjeu
effectivement structurant pour ces
territoires mais aucune réponse n'est
apportée aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
pour accompagner les communes
à réussir la mise en application sans
entraver en réalité leur développement
et en permettant l'accueil de population
donc il faut redonner de des
possibilités de développement pour cette
torrent ruraux tout en respectant
l'objectif du Zen que l'on partage par
ailleurs
pour les raisons que l'on sait liées
notamment à la biodiversité donc c'est
amendement propose d'expérimenter une
aide aux mères ruraux
pour des opérations dédiées à la
réhabilitation la rénovation ou
l'adaptation de l'habitat ainsi que les
opérations de reconversion du bâti
et la commission
que Montauger soulève évidemment
un sujet important plus qu'important
monsieur le ministre et alors en l'état
c'est un amendement que
qui me semble pas de voir pouvoir être
adopté parce que on est à priori
nombreux à ne pas être dans une
opposition entre l'urbain le rural je
pense qu'il faudrait par ailleurs
définir des seuils il faut définir la
ruralité le cas échéant il y a des tas
de sujets techniques sur lesquels
évidemment il faut se prononcer sur
lesquels se prononcera la mission nos
conjoints de contrôle le 14 décembre je
profite pour pour le dire on va faire
des propositions je pense très forte
mais je vois monsieur le ministre dans
l'amendement de Monsieur Montauger un
appel à ce que vous preniez la mesure de
la situation en ce qui concerne Lausanne
vous voyez Lausanne il est disséminé
dans tous les amendements il impacte la
ruralité l'urbain le péril urbain les
grands projets le logement le logement
social même la rue Monsieur le Ministre
et il met en fusion tout ce palais voilà
il faut que vous le sachiez voilà de
sorte que tous les groupes toutes les
commissions se sont mises d'accord pour
que cette se mette en place cette
mission conjointe de contrôle et qui va
faire des propositions extrêmement
fortes qui auront vocation à devenir une
proposition de loi assez rapidement et
on dit pas qu'on est contre Lausanne on
dit juste que on veut des
assouplissements des aménagements du
délai des moyens de l'ingénierie on veut
tout ça voilà alors ça va un peu mieux
faut le dire il y a un petit peu plus de
prise de conscience avec ce gouvernement
mais maintenant on attend les fameuses
preuves d'amour alors en attendant
l'épreuve d'amour on va faire le premier
pas dès le 14 décembre voilà donc ce
sera retrait sinon défavorable mais
Franck motoger faut le prendre au
sérieux là parce que ce qui ce qu'il dit
nous sommes bons bon nombre même très
très nombreux à le partager
du gouvernement monsieur le ministre
oui je madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs vous l'avez
compris le sujet de 0 artificialisation
dette est un sujet largement prise en
compte par l'ensemble du gouvernement le
président de la République en a parlé
lors de son discours au maire pendant le
pendant le congrès
mon collègue Christophe Béchu a pris à
Saint-Andre d'engagement auprès de vous
pour continuer à travailler vous venez
de vous venez de le rappeler bien
évidemment ce chantier est en cours pour
que tout à la fois on puisse avoir une
démarche
écologique mais en même temps ne pas
brimer les territoires dans leur volonté
de développement de développement en
termes de logement de développement en
termes et économique et comme l'a dit le
président de la République et la
première ministre un certain nombre
d'évolutions sont déjà dans les têtes
notamment
sur des projets nationaux et la manière
dont ils seront dont ils seront regardés
l'échelle du zan est fait partie des
sujets sur lesquels il y a à travailler
et toutes les portes sont ouvertes merci
merci alors
présidente à l'adresse de l'ensemble de
mes collègues ici présents et du
ministre aussi moi j'adore l'épreuve
d'amour c'est pas vous voilà et là elle
tarde quand même à venir on a
effectivement un des intentions tout à
fait louable qu'on peut partager mais en
or de ça rien quoi donc voilà par
principe et compte tenu l'enjeu de
l'importance du sujet j'ai bien entendu
qu'il y avait un travail de fond qui
nous serait présenté dans dans peu je ne
retire pas cet amendement et donc je
souhaite qu'on puisse le voter merci
merci alors je me vois donc l'amendement
1059 qui a reçu un avis défavorable de
la commission du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre
n'est pas adopté
l'amendement 1008 du président requier
chaque collègue le programme habité
facile de
la la qui permet de mener politique
d'adaptation des logements
vieillissement et doté de 35 millions
d'euros le distributive m'a imprime
adapte à mis en place en 2024 pour afin
de simplifier les aides actuelles par la
création d'une aide unique à
l'adaptation à la perte d'autonomie nous
souhaitons également les personnes en
situation de handicap et pas seulement
aux personnes âgées
à cette fin pour une prise en charge de
l'autonomie plus globale quelle que soit
l'âge ou la situation de handicap merci
la vie de la Commission
la Présidente c'est monsieur le
Président Reiki et il nous semble que
c'est amendement est déjà satisfait donc
j'en comprends difficilement le l'objet
par ailleurs il faut noter qu'il existe
des toutes sortes d'aides plusieurs
sortes d'aides j'en citerai
quelques-unes très rapidement un crédit
d'impôt pour les travaux une prestation
de compensation pour le handicap versé
par les conseillers départementaux un
prêt travaux accordé par Action Logement
pour les travailleurs handicapés
donc à ce stade je ne veux pas je vois
pas d'autre solution ils vont demander
le retrait sinon défavorable merci la
vidéo gouvernement monsieur le ministre
mais ma vie que monsieur le rapporteur
effectivement c'est satisfait dans le
cadre de
l'amendement est retiré merci amendement
1009 président Ruquier
fait référence aux personnes sans
domicile stable qui sont écartés de la
guerre des effectif de l'ensemble de
leurs droits en matière sociale de la
moindre démarche administrative de la
scolarisation de leurs enfants ou de
l'accès à l'emploi c'est la loi DALO du
Saint-Mars 2007 reconnaît le droit à
domiciliation comme un droit opposable
le nombre d'élections de domiciliation a
connu hausse signée négative et rivière
auprès des centres communaux
intercommunaux d'action sociale ou bien
aussi bien que les organismes agréés ces
derniers sont particulièrement saturés
des crédits de cette vidéo 500.000 euros
en 2021 puis en 2022 ont été alloués à
ces organismes mais la longue
pérennisation des crédits perturent leur
fonctionnement le préservendement
propose donc de consacrer 10 millions
d'euros supplémentaires au financement
des associations notamment des
dispositifs de la veille sociale afin de
leur permettre d'assurer l'effectivité
du droit à domiciliation des personnes
sans-abri ou en situation de même
logement
si la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
que cette possibilité de lire domicile
auprès d'un CCAS et autres organismes
mais évidemment il y a la question qui
suit c'est celle du financement de ces
organismes agréés on ne voit pas de
trace de financement dans les documents
budgétaires donc je sollicite la vie du
gouvernement merci Monsieur le Ministre
la vie du gouvernement donc
merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Sénateur le
renforcement des moyens alloués à la
domiciliation et déjà prévu au titre de
la stratégie prévention et élu contre la
la grande pauvreté vous avez raison
c'est un élément essentiel pour un
certain nombre de nos concitoyens en
grande fragilité pour ma part le
financement de cette mesure est prévu
sur le programme 304 inclusion sociale
et protection des personnes du ministère
de la Solidarité et de la santé action
19 stratégie interministérielle de
prévention et de lutte contre la
pauvreté pardon à hauteur de 7,2
millions en 2022 et 10 millions en 2023
et donc l'amendement est déjà satisfait
merci alors Monsieur requier vous
retirez votre amendement
et retirez merci
[Musique]
alors donc je mets au revoir
l'amendement 1009 carnet favorable de la
commission du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopter
monsieur le Président Roquier c'est à
vous pour le 1052
des moyens nécessaires pour effectuer à
l'accompagnement de proximité auprès des
tournements de collectivités rurales et
hyper rurales qui n'ont pas de moyens en
ingénierie territoriale un blog de 20
millions d'euros qui devait être affecté
au fur et à mesure et j'ai utilisé pour
financer en partie les chefs de projets
des petites villes de demain le
présentement donne à conforter les
besoins de la matière en augmentant de
10 millions d'euros cette enveloppes
pour apporter à 30 millions d'euros en
2023 ils agit ainsi rétablir par des
moyens d’ingénierie dédiées et renforcés
la possibilité effectivement pour les
petites collectivités territoriales soit
de répondre aux appels à projet soit de
monter les progression mesure notamment
en matière de transition écologique
énergétique sera forcément des moyens
dédiés permettra à la croître à
l'efficacité de l'unct et de rendre sa
version plus visible dans les honoraires
les auteurs de l'avendement souhaitent
par ailleurs la tenue de permanence
régulière de ces ingénieurs territoriaux
notamment dans les sous-préfectures
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
alors cet amendement est identique au
1061 que nous avons examiné tout à
l'heure avec une somme qui qui est
différente et donc les arguments que
j'ai développé tout à l'heure pour
demander un retrait reste évidemment
d'actualité pour celui-là
la vidéo gouvernement mais ma vie que
monsieur le rapporteur merci les retiré
merci retirez la maman 1079 madame
linman
et chers collègues l'APL versé avec une
franchise c'est-à-dire que quand les
gens ont droit à une aide personnalisée
au logement inférieur à 24 euros il ne
la touche pas or 24 euros c'est pas une
petite somme en tout cas pour un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens ça fait 288
euros par an donc nous trouvons tout à
fait injuste que des droits qui sont
reconnus ne soient pas finalement
touchés par nos concitoyens nous
demandons donc que l'APS soit versé au
premier euro
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
bien évidemment mais ce que je souhaite
aussi verser au débat c'est le fait que
c'est la représenterait une complexité
non proportionnée à l'aide certes très
limité et par ailleurs écoute gestion
qu'on soulève ça et là donc en l'état ce
serait un retrait que je propose merci
la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
de notre analyse le seuil de non
versement a été diminué de 15 à 10 euros
pour faire suite à baisse des appels
donc il est il est très bas par rapport
au montant moyen des aides personnelles
même si comme la dit Monsieur rapporteur
il y a pas de de petites sommes et
l'absence n'a pas d'impact significatif
sur sur le taux d'efforts donc à ce
stade je suis favorable à un retrait ou
un avis défavorable sur cet abonnement
cet amendement pardon merci
l'État a juste titre s'interroge sur le
non recours et quand il y a des droits
l'état s'arrange pour qu'il ne soit pas
garantis vous n'allez pas m'expliquer
qu'avec la complexité de la
contemporanéité du versement des aides
bien plus compliquées à mon avis que ce
système de versement quand les les APL
sont faibles et puis par ailleurs rien
n'empêcherait l'état de décider d'un
cumul et donne les verser que
trimestriellement ou un moment où
effectivement il y a moins d'acte
technique à opérer donc je maintiens cet
amendement merci alors je me vois la
maman 1079 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
qui s'abstient n'est pas adopté pendant
372 madame Estrosi ça sonne
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre cet amendement concerne les
services intégrés de l'accueil et de
l'orientation ce qu'on appelle les SIAO
qui sont nous savons tous des acteurs
centraux de la régulation du dispositif
d'hébergement et de logement adapté mais
qui sont aussi la clé de voûte et la
cheville ouvrière de la politique
publique de l'État en matière de lutte
contre le sans-abrisme et du service
public de la rue au logement compte tenu
des objectifs particulièrement ambitieux
que le gouvernement a fixé au SIAO et de
ses missions qui ne cessent de croître
pour l'ensemble des personnes qui
travaillent à l'intérieur de ces
services il nous a semblé important que
nous puissions à travers cet amendement
proposé que tous les personnels des
services intégrés d'accueil et
d'orientation qui assurent la prise en
charge des difficultés en grande des
personnes en grande difficulté puissent
pouvoir bénéficier d'une revalorisation
de la rémunération du secteur et je
pense en particulier aux écoutants du
115 qui sont extrêmement sollicités qui
doivent faire appel quotidiennement à la
détresse des appelants qui sont souvent
confrontés à un contexte de saturation
de l'hébergement qui ne leur permet pas
d'apporter des réponses satisfaisantes
aux personnes qui font appel au 115 et
pour toutes ces raisons nous pensons
sincèrement que un geste en faveur de
ces personnels et plus particulièrement
des écoutants du 115 seraient
particulièrement appréciées quant à la
revalorisation de leur rémunération
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
madame la Présidente pour dire que je
m'inscris dans l'EHPAD sénatrice ça
sonne pour dire que les services
intégrés de l'accueil de l'orientation
joue un rôle clé qu'ils ont connu des
réformes importantes que leur travail
est difficile qu'il appelle une
revalorisation
cela peut s'entendre bien entendu
mais il est à noter aussi que que le
taux de réponse étant a priori faible il
n'y a plus d'indicateurs budgétaires qui
a été supprimé donc difficulté à
apprécier tout cela
une difficulté donc il peut apparaître
comme systémique
donc au final je comprends l'intention
qui est excellente mais difficile à
apprécier parce qu'on n'a pas
d'indicateurs précisément donc je
sollicite la vie du gouvernement
merci alors la vie du gouvernement
monsieur le ministre très attendu
madame madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vous avez raison les accueils
enfin les services d'accueil et
d'orientation les scie à haut sont des
acteurs centraux de la régulation du
dispositif de l'hébergement et pour
avoir été moi-même un certain nombre de
soirs les rencontrer et voir la qualité
de leur engagement et la difficulté de
de leur travail je m'associe à vous dans
le cette volonté de les encourager et de
reconnaître l'extrême difficulté vous le
savez dans la dans la continuité du
déploiement du du dispositif logement
d'abord le gouvernement affirmé par
l'instruction du 31 mars 2022 une
ambition forte pour les SIAO acteur clé
de voûte comme vous l'avez rappelé du
service public de la rue au logement
la première ministre la dit et afin de
soutenir l'engagement quotidien de ces
acteurs de première ligne le
gouvernement souhaite effectivement
reconnaître la qualité du travail mené
en attribuant une prime au salarié de
ces structures et SIAO et donc je
confirme l'annonce de la première
ministre avec le versement d'une prime
en 2023 les modalités de cette prime
doivent encore faire l'objet d'un
travail mais seront présentés sous
quelques semaines au plus et feront
l'objet d'une régularisation en cours
d'année prochaine avec un passage devant
la représentation nationale à cette
occasion dans l'attente et avec cet
engagement je vous propose donc de
retirer votre amendement à défaut mais
la vie sera défavorable mais je vous
assure que cette prime est en cours de
préparation
merci Madame Estrosi Sassone
non je ne vais pas retirer cet
amendement d'abord parce qu'on l'a
présenté aussi au nom de la commission
des affaires économiques qu'il est
largement partagé par l'ensemble des
bandes cette hémicycle certes vous nous
prenez un engagement ou la première
ministre la prise disant que il y aura
une prime qui va être versée au
personnel des SIAO nous nous pensons
considérablement que c'est pas une prime
qu'il faut leur accorder mais si on veut
véritablement continuer à les
accompagner dans ses missions qui sont
de plus en plus difficultés difficiles
et leur montrer que nous sommes aussi à
leurs côtés mais que vous le
gouvernement vous comptez beaucoup sur
eux pour mettre en place l'ensemble des
missions que vous souhaitez sur
l'hébergement le logement d'abord le
service public de la rue au logement
c'est une revalorisation de leur salaire
et c'est véritablement permettre aussi à
ce qu'il y ait demain d'autres personnes
qui s'engagent sur ces métiers là parce
qu'on risque aussi de craindre qu'il y
ait une désinfection des personnes sur
ce type de métier
merci alors je mets aux voix la maman
372 qui a donc reçu un avis défavorable
de la commission du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui compte
qui s'abstient il est donc adopté
le 930 monsieur le Président malgré
merci madame la Présidente c'est un
moment visa doubler les moyens consacrés
à l'Agence nationale de cohésion des
territoires afin de soutenir son action
dans le cadre de l'action France mobile
un New Deal a été conçu conclu en
janvier 2018 entre le gouvernement
larsep et les opérateurs mobiles
historiques pour généraliser la
couverture 4G partout en France après
une montée en charge progressive au
cours des premières années cet accord
engage les opérateurs à assurer la
couverture réseau de 806 en zone non ou
mal couverte or les élus locaux font
aujourd'hui valoir que ce rythme est
trop lent en particulier n'a pas été
révisé à la hausse depuis la pandémie
alors même que le besoin en couverture
réseau des zones rurales n'a jamais été
aussi fort compte tenu de la montée en
puissance du télétravail et de la
nouvelle attractivité des communes
rurales
c'est pourquoi cet amendement propose de
doubler les moyens consacrés à la NCT
afin d'augmenter le rythme de ce
déploiement et répondre ainsi à la
demande des territoires ruraux qui se
sentent mis à l'écart du dispositif
France mobile merci alors chers
collègues chers collègues avant de vous
merci voilà il est 13h vous l'avez vu il
reste 18 amendements à étudier
le gouvernement la commission des
finances sont d'accord pour que on aille
un peu plus tard et terminer en fait
crédit de la mission alors est-ce que
quelqu'un s'oppose en fait à ça
non je ne vois pas donc on prolonge
pas trop long quand même mais en tout
cas on prolonge maintenant je vais
demander l'avis de la commission sur
l'amendement 930 monsieur rapporteur
manuré vise ça a été dit à doubler les
crédits destinés au New Deal mobile
alors
en abondant à hauteur de 5,6 millions
d'euros alors certes le déploiement
d'une odeal est bien piloté par la NCT
et par l'ARCEP d'ailleurs
en revanche je pense que les crédits ne
figurent pas sur la maison sur la
mission cohésion des territoires et donc
j'avoue que je n'en connais pas le
montant alors si je comprends bien en
toute logique si en abondant de 5,6
millions je double les crédits ça veut
dire que ça veut dire que les crédits
sont aujourd'hui à peu près à 2,8
millions d'euros du coup je connais pas
exactement le montant qui est consacré
je pense que ça relève pas de la mission
en cohésion des territoires du coup
peut-être le gouvernement monsieur le
ministre vous nous en direz de plus sur
le sujet c'était en tous les cas c'est
un avis du gouvernement même si
évidemment je partage objectif et que le
sujet est extrêmement important
merci madame le Président pour aller
vite juste c'est le New Deal c'est 3
milliards aujourd'hui donc c'est un
investissement extrêmement important
mais effectivement sur sur d'autres
crédits donc je propose ou un retrait ou
un avis défavorable merci je mets au
foie
non vous retirez d'accord merci beaucoup
vous vouliez prendre la parole je crois
oui madame la Présidente suite à votre
demande en à la réalité à la demande du
gouvernement vous avez proposé d'aller
un peu plus loin
je crois qu'il faut mettre l'explication
de texte qui va avec un peu plus loin
c'est pas 14h parce que
tout simplement on avait un rendement au
rythme actuel c'est une heure donc ça
veut donc dire que sur des amendements
qui auraient peut-être un peu moins de
profondeur que d'autres
on irait assez vite et garder sur les
amendements qui ont vraiment beaucoup de
sens faut garder un peu de temps voilà
pour le reste présentation
lacunaire on va dire mais tout le monde
a le texte donc tout va bien et puis
ensuite voilà pas de doublons etc et on
reprend pas la parole en fait et nos
rapporteurs et le ministre ça se
traînent également à une limite leur
position merci merci monsieur le
Président alors deux amendements donc
ils font l'objet d'une discussion
commune de 1140 peut se faire nique
un amendement profond et censé mais une
présentation néanmoins sommaire les
circonstances l'exigent donc qui propose
de renforcer l'accompagnement et le
conseil en mobilité sur tout le
territoire
urbain comme rural en dotant les maisons
France services d'une compétence
d'accompagnement et de conseils en
mobilité
pour l'urbain j'ai pas besoin d'insister
et l'excellent travail de notre collègue
chacun sur les mobilités en zone
prudence à établi l'enjeu essentiel dans
le rural aussi du conseil en mobilité
durable merci le 167
Belin il est défendu
monsieur le rapporteur
encore une fois on l'avait tout à
l'heure l'idée d'informer les habitants
qui sont au proche de zones on est
d'accord en revanche je pense que le
ciblage des maisons France service n'est
pas bon vous avez des départements
entiers qui ont beaucoup de mes enfants
services c'est pas du tout de ZFE et à
l'inverse des zones ZFE dans lesquelles
il y a pas de maison France services
donc je pense que le ciblage sur le
maisons France service n'est pas devant
ciblage on est d'accord sur l'objectif
donc votre défavorable sur les deux
la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre même avis quel rapport ok alors
je mets au voile 1140 qui a reçu un avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient n'est pas
adopté le 167 est retiré monsieur Belin
merci beaucoup
alors l'amendement 84 merci madame la
Présidente c'est amendement visa
augmenté d'un million 55000 euros les
crédits de paiement de l'action 1 action
territorialisée dispositif spécifiques
de la politique de la ville du programme
147 cet abonnement pour objectif de
renforcer dédié les au bataillon de la
prévention qui doivent mobiliser en
binôme 300 éducateurs spécialisés et 300
médiateurs adultes relais or les
collectivités peinent à recruter ces
éducateurs sur des postes à durée
limitée et moins bien rémunéré que ce
que les mêmes profils peuvent trouver
dans le secteur médico-social qui a
bénéficié d'une revalorisation décidée
par le gouvernement le déférentiel est
ainsi de 183 euros net par mois et par
poste 293 euros avec des charges
l'abondement permettra de combler cette
différence sur une année complète qui ne
doit pas rester à la charge des
collectivités cette augmentation est
formellement gagée sur l'action 4 du
programme 135 pour assurer la
subalabilité de l'amendement merci
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
je sollicite la vie du gouvernement si
Monsieur le Ministre votre avis avec
sobriété
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice vous le savez les bataillons
de la prévention ont été mises en place
après le CIV de janvier 2021 ils se sont
concrétisés par le déploiement
progressif de 600 médiateurs à la fois
donc sur des postes d'adultes relais et
d'éducateur spécialisé dans une
quarantaine de quartiers en particulier
dans les quartiers de reconquête
républicaine ce dispositif est toujours
en cours en phase d'évaluation oui les
difficultés existent pour le recrutement
des éducateurs spécialisés des
difficultés de dans le cadre de la
formation des difficultés dans le cadre
de la pérennisation des postes notamment
pour les éducateurs spécialisés portés
par la Prévention Spécialisée
départementale mais je ne suis pas
certain que ça ne soit qu'à un problème
dossier et et de
pour pérenniser et pour recruter ses
postes c'est un métier qui a besoin
d'être revalorisé et accompagner à ce
stade je serai un avis défavorable pour
continuer à évaluer ce dispositif et ne
pas prendre une mesure
unilatérale qui ne serait pas être mis
en œuvre
merci alors je me vois l'amendement
pour intervenir quand même je crois que
c'est postes sont extrêmement importants
sur les territoires et je redis certes
la rémunération n'est pas la seule le
seul frein au recrutement mais c'est ce
que nous ont renvoyé les territoires que
nous avons vu s'il y a des vraiment des
difficultés de recrutement parce que
c'est un métier qui peut attractif comme
d'autres bien sûr mais nous devons en
tenir compte merci je pense que voilà
merci beaucoup donc je mets aux voix la
maman 95 qui a reçu donc un avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui ça tient et pas
adopté deux amendements faisant l'objet
d'une discussion commune le 65 est
défendu oui madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la loi 3DS dans son article 91 un store
un nouveau critère de recours au titre
du droit au logement opposable désormais
une personne en situation de handicap
logée dans un logement inadapté peut
entamer un recours à l'amiable ou en
contentieux pour être relogé aussi notre
collègue Philippe Moulié propose cette
amendement qui vise à donner les moyens
au pouvoir public de garantir une offre
de logement et de mieux recenser l'offre
de logement accessible je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président Roquier pour
le 1007 il est défendu merci la vie de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
notamment pour savoir quel est son
estimation du coût des conséquences de
la loi 3 des 3DS sur le contentieux même
si la vie du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre sur ces deux amendements
en 2022 afin de répondre à la
problématique du handicap dans le
logement le gouvernement a choisi
d'instaurer dans la loi 3DS un nouveau
critère de reconnaissance au titre du
droit au logement opposable DALO pour
les personnes en situation de handicap
logé dans un logement handicap un
logement inadapté pardon cette mesure va
accroître le nombre de recours devant
les commissions en haut une hausse
attendue de 10% pour l'année 2023 le
gouvernement a tenu compte de cette
hausse dans le PLF 2023 en programmant 4
millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaires dédié aux contentieux
DALO ainsi ceux-ci progresse de 35 à 39
millions d'euros PLF 2023 ce qui
représente une augmentation de
11,4%. donc
à ce titre les motifs de cet amendement
nous semblent satisfaits et j'aimais
donc un avis défavorable
donc le 65 est retiré
retiré le 1007
retiré merci beaucoup avant 3
monsieur Belin monsieur chevrolier
monsieur Chevrier oui merci madame la
Présidente l'eau est un sujet majeur
dans ce plan de la quantité que la
qualité et c'est un moment proposé par
la Commission et développement durable
par notre collègue lui Jean de Nicolaï
vise à augmenter d'un million d'euros
les montants de financement mobilisés
par l'État pour la qualité de l'eau dans
la très belle région des Pays de la
Loire que l'honneur d'être un
représentant de cette région donc
j'aurais pu voir le défendre et j'espère
que mon collègue Bruno Belin n'en voudra
pas je vous remercie merci
alors la vie de la commission alors
comme ça a été dit cet amendement
prévoit d'augmenter de 1 million d'euros
l'action 11 du programme des
interventions territoriales de l'État
qui porte sur la qualité d'eau dans les
Pays de Loire
c'est vrai que ce pour 2023 le projet de
loi pour 2023 prévoit seulement 700000 €
pour cette action et donc compte tenu
des enjeux qu'il y a c'est un avis de
sagesse de la commission qui permettrait
de porter le montant de 700000 euros à
un million 700000 merci la vie du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre la vie
du Gouvernement est défavorable
je me vois la maman 360 carrossier en
avis de sagesse de la Commission et
défavorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
donc adapté madame jasmin pour le 104
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre notre amendement a pour objet
de rompu égalité une inégalité et de
rectifier en quelque sorte une situation
qui n'est plus qui n'a plus d'objets en
quelque sorte la proportion de famille
de plus de 6 enfants à notre mère par
rapport à celle de l'Hexagone ne
justifie pas les mesures qui sont
jusqu'à maintenant pris c'est un
manquement est aussi l'occasion
d'évoquer la question du tournage qui ne
correspond plus aux réalités vécues sur
les territoires c'est particulièrement
probant pour les territoires d'outre-mer
classés en zone géographique 2 alors que
les prix des loyers en outre-mer se
rapprochent des Franciliens justifiant
la modification des images l'amendement
propose d'abonder le crédit du programme
109 aide à l'accès au logement action 01
aide personnelle à hauteur de 1 million
d'euros pour assurer la recevabilité
financière d'un amendement c'est
abondant c'est un
sur l'action 4 du programme 135
urbanisme territoire et amélioration de
l'habitat
si la vie de la commission sur le
rapporteur
madame la sénatrice nous partageons
l'objectif de la mesure
proposée puisque effectivement cette
mesure de différenciation pour les
familles de plus de 6 enfants en
outre-mer et dans l'Hexagone ne se
justifie plus et donc un arrêté sera
publié dans les prochaines semaines afin
de mettre fin à la limite de 6 enfants
dans la prise en compte du calcul des
allocations logement en outre-mer cette
mesure qui relève du domaine
réglementaire étant en cours de prise en
compte je vous propose de retirer cette
amendement merci
[Musique]
monsieur le ministre alors j'ai bien
entendu vos arguments j'espère que ce
sera réellement suivi des faits je vous
remercie donc je retiens merci donc
l'amendement 1050 présidents requier
[Musique]
de recruter 23 janvier de projet de mis
à disposition de manière déconcentrée un
par région les directeurs métropolitains
et la Corse un par région et par
département d'outre-mer et même pas
collectivité d'outre-mer pas pour
Saint-Martin pour Saint-Barthélemy ça
coûte 850 2000 euros merci la vie de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
alors cet amendement prévoir un crédit
800.000 euros un petit peu plus 85000
euros pour créer des chefs de projet
attachés à la NCT a raison de 1 par
région plus les territoires d'outre-mer
ça est très dit très franchement je
pense qu'il faut renforcer les
moyennestt mais je pense que les chaînes
régionales n'est pas le bon aujourd'hui
il y a une personne identifiée
d'ailleurs dans chaque département et je
pense qu'il faut renforcer les moyens de
l'anct à l'échelle départementale parce
qu'on reste dans une échelle de
proximité avec les territoires avec les
élus locaux c'est la raison pour
laquelle la Commission demande de
retrait
mais ma vie que le rapporteur retrait ou
défavorable merci retirez merci
amendement 1051 président routier
afin de permettre le recrutement d'une
dizaine d'architectes du conseil et
paysagiste et conseillé de l'État mais à
disposition gratuitement auprès des
collectivités territoriales pour des
cours de missions d'expertise en matière
d'architecture d'urbanisme et de
management du territoire normalement
merci la vie de la commission sur le
rapporteur
merci Monsieur le Ministre la vie du
gouvernement même avis oui le même avis
dans notre analyse c'est un moment est
déjà satisfait merci retirez-vous
retirez merci même comme pour le 1057
oui madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers
n'est pas profond il est dramatique
comme vous le savez les îles de
Guadeloupe et de Martinique ont été
impactés par le plus le plus dur le plus
méchant des pesticides le chlore des
cônes qui empoisonne à la fois les
humains mais aussi les terres de ces
pays pour au moins 700 ans donc
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que pour nous
servir de l'eau potable et donc
dépolluer au robinet les collectivités
font des efforts énormes coûteuses
coûteux pour entre autres assainir l'eau
avec des filtres à charbon si le seul
moyen qui existe aujourd'hui pour nous
permettre d'avoir de l'eau non polluée
au robinet cette charge est justement à
la charge des collectivités et pourtant
le Président de la République de manière
très singulière et je salue cette
reconnaissance a reconnu la
responsabilité de l'État dans
l'empoisonnement au clan des cônes à la
Martinique et à la Guadeloupe donc il me
semble cohérent il me semble juste il me
semble équitable que c'est au pollueur à
l'état qui l'a reconnu de porter la
charge qui est estimée pour cette
première année à 400.000 euros des frais
de dépollution et en particulier d'achat
de filtre à charbon qui permettent
d'arrêter de polluer et de porter cancer
aux habitants de Guadeloupe et
Martinique j'espère en tout cas que
il y aura un regard
attentionné à cet amendement merci chers
collègues la vie de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur
alors le regard de la Commission tient
compte évidemment de des enjeux qui ont
été rappelés par notre collecteurs et on
reviendra pas sur le sur le sujet du
coup l'État intervient à travers le plan
corps des cône cœur déconne en
Martinique et en Guadeloupe et à travers
un programme des interventions
territoriales de l'État ce qu'on appelle
le pit ce qui est prévu dans le but
projet de budget pour
2023 c'est 4,5 millions d'euros vous
proposez d'augmenter ces crédits à
hauteur de 500 400 000 euros sur une
trompe pas 400000 euros et donc nous
devons un avis favorable à cet
amendement mais je tiens à préciser
quand même que finalement le Parlement a
assez peu de lisibilité pour cette
action là pour deux comme pour d'autres
actions d'ailleurs du programme des
interventions territoriales de l'État
parce qu'en cours d'année il y a des
transferts en gestion finalement qui
échappent finalement à la visibilité du
Parlement et l'année dernière en plus de
ce qui a été voté dans la loi de
finances en 2022 et 1,6 millions de
crédits qui ont été transférés en tous
les cas c'est un avis favorable pour
ajouter la somme qui est prévue les 400
000 euros au programme plan que leur
déconne et c'est vrai que les enjeux
sont très importants merci la vie du
gouvernement monsieur
le président madame la sénatrice vous
avez raison le sujet du chlore des codes
est un sujet grave il est une priorité
de nos collègues ministres de
l'outre-mer et du ministère de la Santé
ça a été rappelé un budget inédit et
consacré à la mise en oeuvre du
quatrième plan national de lutte contre
la pollution par le chlore des connes
c'est 92 millions d'euros entre 2021 et
2027 avec 47 mesures dont 42 ont déjà
été lancés et bien évidemment les
crédits du programme 162 ne résume pas
mais pas du tout les actions des
pouvoirs publics en matière de lutte
contre les pollutions par le chlore
bacon l'action est bien plus large avec
des mesures sur la santé l'environnement
l'alimentation la qualité de l'eau comme
vous l'avez dit mais dans la mesure où
on est bien au-delà de ce programme 162
nous vous l'avis du Gouvernement est un
retrait ou sinon un
la Commission est soutenue l'amendement
de notre collègue vous avez vu que les
tribunaux ont arbitré pour considérer
que ne pouvaient pas
juger d'une responsabilité des uns ou
des autres pour des raisons de délai etc
le chef de l'État a dit a juste titre
que l'État était responsable il faut
donc maintenant qu'on soit sûr que cette
responsabilité arrive sur le terrain en
sonnant et trébuchant et j'approuve donc
non seulement l'amendement mais la
remarque de notre rapporteur qui doit
nous mettre le Parlement en vigilance
totale pour être sûr que les engagements
pris soient tenus
merci Madame jasmin
oui je suis oui bien semaine la
présidente moi je suis vraiment très
heureuse de sa voix que la Commission
est donnée un tel avis et ça me permet
également de féliciter le travail de
l'OPEX l'Office Parlementaire des choix
scientifiques et technologiques avec
notre collègue Catherine procacia qui
fait un travail de fond et qui est en
cohérence avec ceux que vient de
proposer ma collègue et Catherine
couronne donc je crois vraiment monsieur
le ministre même s'il y a un certain
nombre d'arguments que vous pouvez
évoquer je crois que la Commission a eu
raison raison de soutenir et je vais ici
également les propos de notre collègue
madame Lindman merci
oui dans ma dans ma discussion générale
d'hier je parlais d'intention vous
imaginez bien monsieur le ministre que
le plan Claude je le connais pas au
coeur que je participe à toutes les
réunions concernant le Clos des cône
j'approuve les sommes qui ont été mises
j'approuve la démarche
il m'arrive même d'aider le gouvernement
à le mettre en oeuvre parce que pour moi
il s'agit pas d'une question politique
il s'agit d'une question humaine il
s'agit de question de santé il y a
aujourd'hui des ouvriers agricoles qui
meurent à cause du chlorure c'est un
drame donc aujourd'hui il faut marquer
des intentions et que des collectivités
et à payer la dépollution de l'eau avec
des moyens de filtrage charbon ce n'est
pas juste
le responsable le pollueur celui qui a
autorisé la diffusion de ce pesticide
violent et dangereux doit prendre en
compte cette dépense et nous sommes là
en train d'examiner une mission cohésion
des territoires
les éléments du plan chlordicône des
éléments qui sont fléchés et vous
imaginez bien qu'avant de porter mon
amendement j'ai fait le taux du plan
Claude aucun aucune ligne ne prévoit
cette dépense de remboursement à la
collectivité locale donc c'est dans ce
sens que je l'ai déposé parce que moi
j'estime que là aussi l'État doit
marquer des intentions extrêmement
fortes et dire aux collectivités locales
nous avons pollué nous vous aidons à
dépolluer si alors je mets aux voix la
Monon 1057 qui a reçu un avis favorable
à la Commission et un avis défavorable
du gouvernement qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
madame Artigalas pour le 94 merci madame
la Présidente cette amendement visa
augmenté de 200000 euros les crédits de
paiement de l'action un du programme 147
et c'est pour avec pour objectif de
relancer l'activité de l'Observatoire
national de la politique de la ville
placé au sein de la NCT en effet le NPV
est devenu une coquille vide il n'a plus
de président depuis un an et ses
effectifs ont été divisés par 5 depuis
son intégration elle a NCT or le besoin
d'évaluation de la politique de la ville
et centrale à la fois pour mesurer les
effets du NPN RU et ceux des politiques
de la ville auprès des populations il
est par exemple nécessaire de créer des
coorts pour suivre les parcours des
bénéficiaires dans la durée dans et en
dehors des quartiers prioritaires de la
politique de la ville cette augmentation
est formellement gagée sur l'action 4 du
programme 135 pour assurer la
recevabilité de l'amendement je vous
remercie merci la vie de la Commission
je souhaiterais savoir pourquoi l'on PV
serait une coquille vide donc naviguer
gouvernement sur le sujet merci David du
gouvernement monsieur ministre
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
monsieur le rapporteur l'ompv et tout
sauf une coquille vous savez
elle doit enfin je crois être un
scientifique et je suis très attaché aux
études et à nos capacités d'évaluation
de de la politique de la ville j'ai fait
des propositions pour renommer un
nouveau ou une nouvelle présidente à
l'omtv on travaillera avec et on
travaille déjà avec l'équipe de la NCT
et son nouveau directeur pour que l'on
PV mais j'ai rencontré les équipes
actuelles donc c'est pour ça que je ne
peux pas accepter qu'on parle d'une
coquille vide puisque c'est il y a des
gens des gens qui travaillent et qui
n'ont jamais cessé de travailler et je
peux vous assurer qu'on leur donnera
tous les moyens nécessaires à évaluer la
politique de la ville comme ils l'ont
toujours fait et j'ai d'ailleurs
souhaité associer en plus de l'ANPE un
nouveau comité scientifique à la
politique de la ville donc je nommerai
un certain nombre des personnes dans les
semaines qui viennent et NPV retrouvera
si ce n'est si elle l'avait réellement
perdu toutes ses capacités à faire et il
s'agit là du budget propre de la NCT
donc à ce stade laissons faire la
direction de la NCT pour donner à la NPV
les moyens de faire son travail merci à
ma présidente
madame la Présidente Monsieur Michel
vers de l'amendement de Madame Artigalas
que bien sûr nous allons soutenir il y a
la nécessité d'avoir au moment où on
veut repartir vers une nouvelle
génération de contrat villes
l'indispensable
nécessité de d'avoir des éléments
d'évaluation statistiques à la hauteur
des coords ça a été dit aujourd'hui on
demande à tous les territoires d'évaluer
leur propre mise en oeuvre des
politiques fin des contrats de villes
qu'ils ont réalisé il faut que l'État
puisse les additionner les analyser voir
dans quelle direction il faut aller que
ce soit dans la territorialisation de la
nouvelle politique de la ville que ce
soit sur le contenu les actions
aujourd'hui on ne remet pas en question
la qualité des professionnels qui sont à
l'intérieur mais leur nombre leur
quantité les moyens réellement dévoluent
avoir une ambitieuse évaluation ça en
laquelle comment on peut s'attendre
avoir une politique de la ville qui
évolue dans le bon sens et qui soit
adapté aux besoins
merci alors je vais mettre au voile un
moment 94 qui a reçu donc un avis
défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
donc adopté nous allons procéder au vote
des crédits de la mission cohésion des
territoires figurant à l'étape je
n'étais saisie d'aucune demande
d'explication de vote avant l'expiration
du délai de limite je vous rappelle que
la commission des finances sans remet à
la sagesse du Sénat pour le vote des
crédits de cette mission
pardon monsieur le rapporteur
attention personnelle c'est ça je mets
au voile les crédits de la mission qui
est pour
qui compte
qui s'abstient
donc ils ne sont pas adoptés
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre la question du financement du
logement social nous préoccupe tous et
je crois pouvoir dire sur l'ensemble des
bancs de cette émission et
corollairement bien sûr la question de
la prolongation de la réduction du loyer
de solidarité l'article 41 ter du PLF
qui est rattaché à la mission justement
pour but de maintenir son rendement à
hauteur de 1,3 milliards d'euros en 2023
l'avenir donc est donc normalement
soumis à la conclusion on l'a dit les
uns les autres d'impact de confiance
avec les bailleurs sociaux sans doute au
printemps prochain et également à la
signature de la convention quinquennale
avec Action Logement la RLS faut-il le
rappeler à essentiellement a été absorbé
par les bailleurs sociaux grâce à un
accroissement de leur endettement or
aujourd'hui la hausse des taux d'intérêt
remet fortement en cause ce modèle ainsi
que la hausse des coûts de production et
le parc social est également confronté à
un objectif impératif et impérieux de
rénovation des logements pour pouvoir
continuer demain à les louer c'est donc
la raison de l'amendement que je vous
propose qui est un amendement qui entend
lancer le débat sur la révision de la
RLS et enfin connaître ce que le
gouvernement en temps faire de la RLS à
partir de 2023 nous nous pensons tous
malheureusement que le gouvernement à
l'intention de la prolonger c'est déjà
le cas d'une année supplémentaire mais
que ça pourrait aller beaucoup plus loin
et nous pensons que dans cette
perspective et surtout dans la
perspective de la signature potentielle
du pacte de confiance au printemps
prochain il est temps que le
gouvernement abattre ses cartes et qui
nous disent véritablement ce qu'il
entend faire au sujet de la RS
prolongation ou pas donc on n'a pas
l'habitude de demander des rapports mais
cet amendement demande un rapport sous
les quatre mois d'ici que le pack de
confiance soit suivi de la commission
monsieur
avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
même la présidente comme ça a été
rappelé nous sommes dans le cadre d'un
travail
partenariat avec le monde HLM et le la
signature d'un pacte de confiance tous
les sujets seront ouverts dans ce
travail de pacte de confiance il y a il
y aura aucun aucun tabou mais à ce stade
je ne vois pas la nécessité d'avoir ce
travail d'études particulier ça sera
donc un avis défavorable merci je mets
au voile à mon nom 73 qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient donc
adopté je me vois l'article 41 TER qui
est pour contre qui ça tient est adopté
après l'article 41 TER deux amendements
identiques madame la Présidente oui même
la présidente effectivement marine
défendra un amendement identique alors
le dispositif de la RLS a pris forme a
pris la forme d'une remise de loyer
financée par les bailleurs sociaux pour
les locataires éligibles sous condition
de ressources à l'APL en contrepartie
d'une baisse concomitante et quasi
équivalente comprise entre 90 et 98% du
montant de la RLS des aides
personnalisées au logement versées à ces
mêmes locataires si l'on entend la
logique d'un tel dispositif à vocation
budgétaire puisqu'il permet 1,3
milliards d'euros par an d'économie pour
l'État sur la période 2022 2022 forcée
de constater que la différence entre la
baisse d'APL de 90 à 98% du montant de
la RLS et la réduction de loyer de
solidarité assumée par les bailleurs
sociaux fait porter à ces derniers seuls
ce coût le coup de ses 10 à 2% restants
le rap un rapport de la Cour des comptes
du 22 décembre 2020 et bien recommande
de simplifier un tel dispositif
polisibles complexe et qui induit un
coup supplémentaire à la charge des
organismes de logement sociaux et par
ailleurs qui rendit visible à quittance
du locataire notamment lorsque des
opérations de régularisation au titre de
plusieurs mois passé doivent intervenir
c'est pour ces raisons que le présente
amendement propose de fixer la
diminution de l'APL verset à hauteur de
la RLS perçue vous comprendrez que
derrière cet amendement certes technique
et complexe il y a un vrai enjeu pour
les bailleurs et pour les locataires
merci mamie man défendue merci la vie de
la Commission sur un porteur c'est une
demande d'avis du gouvernement merci
avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre
même la sénatrice je comprends la mesure
que vous proposez afin de limiter si
j'ose dire le nombre d'erreurs relatives
au versement de la RLS toutefois si le
versement de la RS a été source
d'anomalie je crois qu'elles ont été
depuis régler et dans cette optique je
vous propose d'opter pour une
stabilisation du système actuel plutôt
que de le faire à nouveau évoluer avec
une complexité que vous avez d'ailleurs
vous-même
abordé la modification proposée n'aurait
pas la gestion des indus et rappelle au
niveau des organismes payeurs puisqu'il
y a déjà des régulations régulières sans
que l'écart entre la baisse de l'appel
et la RLS est un impact particulier le
montant de la baisse des appels est déjà
très proche légèrement inférieur du
montant de l'arls cet écart de mort
cependant nécessaire pour éviter que
certains locataires ne soient perdants
avec la RLS du fait des tables de calcul
ultérieur à la formule je rentre pas
dans le détail des règles des arrondis
mais pour toutes ces raisons j'aimais un
avis défavorable merci
le ministre tout n'a pas été réglé dans
la mise en oeuvre de la RLS
techniquement là je parle pas du fond
justement cette dernière point qui reste
deuxièmement complexe à décrire mais
complexe surtout actuellement tel que
c'est à mettre en oeuvre pour les
organismes ça leur coûte cher
inutilement je soutiens donc cet
amendement merci alors je mets aux voix
donc l'amendement 518 pardon qui a reçu
donc un avis défavorable d'accumulation
et du gouvernement qui est pour
qui est contre
ça tient pas adopter alors amendement
107 le 1129 n'est pas défendu même
jasmin oui merci madame la Présidente
alors il s'agit l'un de différenciation
je dirais tout simplement dans la mesure
où il faut quand même valoriser le
travail de Luchon alors Luchon c'est
l'Union Sociale des sociétés
pour l'habitat l'Union Sociale pardon
pour l'habitat à notre mère et il se
trouve que lui chambre joue un rôle
essentiel un rôle de mission d'intérêt
général auprès des collectivités
d'outre-mer et même auprès des élus
parce que quelquefois il nous éclaire ce
sont des personnes ressources alors
le problème de l'habitat social dans
notre mère nécessite qu'il y ait une
réelle volonté de maintenir les actions
complémentaires et en synergie avec
toutes les instances et tous les acteurs
alors il s'agit de bien vivre ensemble
de travailler tous ensemble parce que là
il se trouve que lui chambre ne
bénéficient plus des financements qui
pourraient lui permettre de jouer son
rôle de tirer général alors qu'il est un
des signataires du plan logement aux
premières diables et c'est porteurs de
projets d'intérêt général il importe que
la représentativité de l'action de
Luchon soit inscrite au code de la
construction et de l'habitat pour
permettre notamment la continuité des
projets d'intérêt général qu'il mène
avec les collectivités locales et les
bailleurs sociaux qu'elle représente il
faut le savoir donc il s'agit de
différenciation et je crois que toutes
les actions sont bonnes donc il ne
s'agit pas de faire de différence pour
faire bien mais c'est parce que sais-tu
style pour nos territoires parce que
grâce à Luchon et bien nous sommes
visibles dans les politiques publiques
merci Merci la vie de la Commission sur
rapporteur
pour ne pas introduire de
différenciation la vie du gouvernement
sera défavorable merci Madame Lindemann
tout aussi efficace
enfin je voudrais
on est on nous demande en fait ici
d'arbitrer une forme de conflit plus ou
moins nette entre une partie des
organismes HLM d'outre-mer et l'Union
sociale pour l'habitat je ne pense pas
que ce soit le Sénat qui doivent rentrer
dans ce genre de choses je voudrais dire
que tous les organismes chez les ne sont
pas adhérents du chaumes et je voudrais
quand même noter que le ministre des
Outre-mer invite réellement tous les
partenaires tous les organismes HLM à
discuter notamment du tout nouveau plan
logement outre-mer donc je vous demande
de ne pas voter cet amendement merci
alors je me vois avec mon 1067 qui a
reçu donc un avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui contre qui s'abstient pas adopté
l'amendement 1066 madame jasmin puisque
le 1130 n'est pas défendu
en tout cas on aura bien compris quelle
est la volonté de chacun alors le
supplément de loyer solidarité et se
laisse et appeler de façon anticipée à
notre mère ce qui crée une inégalité de
traitement entre les locataires du parc
HLM en outre-mer et en hexagone alors il
faut savoir que les ultramarins payent
cotisent comme tout le monde sauf que
dans la réalité il ne bénéficie pas
alors que pour le Fond national d'aide à
la pierre et bien tout le monde peut
aller tout le monde cotise l'activité
aussi par contre pour en bénéficier et
bien les ultras marins ne bénéficient
pas pour les prêts locatifs aidés
d'interrogations donc je voudrais quand
même qu'il y ait une réparation de cette
injustice et que l'ensemble des
cotisants et des territoires qui
cotisent puissent bénéficier de cette
possibilité d'obtenir des prêts locatifs
et des d'intégration pour les personnes
qui le méritent merci
si la vie de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
merci
donc je mets aux voix l'amendement 1066
qui a reçu donc un avis défavorable de
la commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour
qui est contre
le 1081
OK et le
476 monsieur Belin est défendu oui c'est
un amendement essentiel qu'on voit la
liste des consignatères et leurs
qualités c'est pour aller sur les
petites villes de demain avec des
crédits dédiés non pas fléchés que la
DETR
je vous remercie beaucoup la vie de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
alors ce rapport fait écho c'est quoi un
rapport qui a mené la délégation
collectivité territoriale et la
décentralisation et dans lequel Rémy
pintro qui porte cette amendement c'est
beaucoup investi le rapport à la
délégation demande un fond dédié au
programme petite ville de demain et moi
j'y suis j'y suis bien sûr favorable
alors après il évalue à 2 milliards
c'est à regarder en tous les cas
aujourd'hui il y a pas de crédit dédié à
l'investissement dans la petite ville de
demain en revanche cet amendement ne
crée pas le fond cet amendement de bande
un rapport au gouvernement et moi je
pense que c'est pas par un rapport au
gouvernement qu'on va créer le fond il
faut qu'on directement on passe une
proposition de création d'un fond dédié
aux investissements dans les programmes
petite ville de demain c'est la raison
pour laquelle la Commission propose un
retrait
si même avis monsieur le ministre même
avis retrait ou défavorable merci de
retirer merci beaucoup je vais donner la
parole à Monsieur le Président Claude
rénal président de la commission des
finances
oui merci madame la Présidente et merci
d'avoir accepté de prolonger un petit
peu pour tout le monde vous serez-il
possible donc je vais simplement
indiquer que je demande l'examen séparé
de certains amendements de la mission
écologique qui vient cet après-midi pour
permettre les regroupements thématiques
et éviter une trop longue discussion
commune un sujet qui s'est posé à
multiples reprises durant cette semaine
voilà merci monsieur le Président il n'y
a pas d'opposition je n'en vois pas il
en est ainsi décidé j'informe le Sénacle
des candidatures pour siéger au sein de
l'éventuelle commission mixte paritaire
sur le projet de loi de finance pour
2023 ont été publiés ces candidatures
seront ratifiées si la présidence n'a
pas reçu d'opposition dans le délai
d'une heure prévue par notre règlement
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 15h10 pour l'examen de la
mission écologie développement et
mobilité durable la séance est suspendue